FLORA NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM. THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS
WILL PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND
BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THE CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA OUR
QUE HAN. BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM.
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA LOW BURKE
CALDERON. RIO CERVANTES CHAO
GEN DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DEEP EGGMAN FLORA FONG. FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LEE MODE.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON. DOORS
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA. RAMOS RAY IS
LOOSE REBAJAS ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SMITH STONE TING VOEPEL WALDRON
WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY OSHA REDUCED.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. A BRIEF REFLECTION
ON LAUGHTER. LIVING THROUGH THE
CHANGES AND CHALLENGES OF LIFE
WE MAY FIND THAT OUR ABILITY TO
LAUGH CAN BE OUR TEACHER OUR
FRIEND IN EVEN HEALING
MEDICINE. SHARING NOW AFTER CAN
INDICATE THE BEGINNING OF
FRIENDSHIP. AND SOMEONE MAKES
US LAUGH IT CAN BE THE
BEGINNING OF LOVE. EDUCATORS
HAVE SAID THAT WE LEARN AND
RETAIN MORE OF WHEN WE LAUGH.
AND WE ARE OFTEN HEARD THE
PHRASE LAUGHTER IS THE BEST
MEDICINE. IT CAN BE DEBATED
THAT LAUGHTER IS UNIQUELY
HUMAN. WHAT IS CERTAIN A
UNIQUELY HUMAN IS THAT WE ARE
FINITE BEANS THEY HAVE
IMAGINATION TO CONTEMPLATE
INFINITY. IN LIVING THROUGH THE
IN AN EFFORT TO BOTH CHANGES
AND DIFFICULT CHALLENGES OF
LIFE. WE MAY FIND THAT OUR
ABILITY TO LAUGH CAN BE OUR
TEACHER OUR FRIEND AND EVEN
HEALING MEDICINE. NUMBER ONE
THE NUMBER WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS. THANK
YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER ISSUE. MASON
GERMAN PLEASE JOIN IN THE
PLEDGE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. AND
TO WHICH IT STANDS. IS. THANK
YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY AUGUST TWENTY NINTH
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN INTO MY
BED AT SEVEN AM THE AUDIBLE
WHERE PEOPLE SO WHENEVER. SEVEN
SEVEN THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR DOZEN
WASN'T AT THE DESK. CALDERON
MOVES. AND MR LACKEY SECONDS
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED. SHE
JUST FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE. THERE ARE NONE. MOVING
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
THERE ARE NO ABSENCES TODAY
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS TO
SPEAK ON IN GERMANY MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES WITHDRAW THE
FOLLOWING BILLS IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TEAM TO TAKE HIM
UP TODAY WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD
READING ESPYS ONE OR NINE ONE
TWELVE AND ONE THIRTEEN.
WITHOUT THAT REQUEST IS
GRANTED. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE READ THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS IN THE FILE.
ITEM SIXTY NINE EIGHTY SIX OF
THREE MELENDEZ AND ITEM SEVENTY
AB TWELVE TWENTY ONE COOLEY.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
WITH THE FOLLOWING BILL C. NECK
TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE SB
SIXTY ACTIONS ITEM NINETY SB
THREE OR TWO PORTANTINO. ITEM
ONE HUNDRED SB ONE THIRTY TWO
WIENER AND I DON'T WANT TO FOR
SB FIVE ANYONE COMING OUT OF.
THE CLERK WILL. PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SEVEN I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER ITEM EIGHTY THREE SB ONE
TEN AND ITEM EIGHTY FOUR SB ONE
ELEVEN TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION I REQUEST IS
GRANTED. SOME. AND MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I'M
REFERRING THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO COMMITTEE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB ONE SIXTEEN TAKING
TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE I DON'T NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB TWO OH ONCE
CERVANTES TO ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE ON ITEM
TWENTY ONE AB FIFTEEN NINETEEN
BY MISTER LOW TO THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY THREE A. B.
THIRTY EIGHT DOCTOR WOULD TO
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE AND THEN TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB SEVEN
TWENTY THREE QUIRK TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN A. B.
FOURTEEN HUNDRED KAMLAGER-DOVE
TO THE LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE AND FINALLY ITEM
NUMBER FORTY TWO. AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY MISTER LOW. TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND MISTER CALDERON
YOU AGAIN RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT WILL SIX TO A THE FALL
NOTICE CHOIR MEANT TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO ME
TOMORROW BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS HERE AB FIVE TWENTY
LOW AB ONE FIFTEEN NINETEEN LOW
AB TO FIFTEEN TWENTY LOW AND AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY TWO LOW UPON.
CALL OF THE CHAIR. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT REQUEST IS
GRANTED ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE HERE AB
TWO A ONCE CERVANTES IN AB SIX
EIGHTY ONE GONZALEZ UPON CALL
THE CHAIR. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT REQUEST IS
GRANTED
. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL FIFTY FOUR.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ.
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. SB ONE OH
NINE. MR TANG WILL PRESENT
CARPORT RATE SENATE BILL ONE OH
NINE BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACCOLADE TO
THE STATE BUDGET. SB ONE OH
NINE IS AN AMENDMENT TO OUR
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
OVERALL THIS BILL IS A NET
SAVINGS OF THIRTY FOUR POINT
TWO MILLION TO THE GENERAL FUND
DUE TO A SHIFT IN FEDERAL CHILD
CARE FUNDS THE DO NOT REDUCE
THE OVERALL LEVEL OF PROGRAM
FUNDING. THE MANY TECHNICAL
CHANGES AND CORRECTIONS IN THIS
BUDGET THREE NEW AREAS OF
EXPENDITURES ARE TWO HUNDRED
AND SIX MILLION A SPECIAL FUNDS
FOR THE DESIGN BUILD PHASE OF
THE SALTON SEA SPECIES
CONSERVATION HABITAT FOURTEEN
POINT NINE MILLION OF GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME TO CAL FIRE TEN
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CENTER
SECURITY GROUP PROGRAM TO
RESPOND TO RECENT. SECURITY
ISSUES WITHOUT RESPECT YES
RIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHANG
MISTER OVERALL DEAR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB ONE OH NINE THIS BILL IT
CONTAINS OVER ONE HUNDRED PAGES
OF APPROPRIATIONS. ADMITTEDLY
MOST OF THOSE APPROPRIATIONS
RUN CONTROVERSIAL BUT IT ALSO
CONTAINS DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
LEGISLATIVE YOUR MARCH WILL BE
COLLOQUIAL COOLEY CALL PORK. I
MENTIONED WHEN WE DEBATED THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR THAT WE HAD
MORE PORK IN THE STATE BUDGET
THIS YEAR THAN IN ANY OTHER
YEAR I'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH
THE BUDGET IN MY TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE. UNFORTUNATELY THIS
TRAILER BILL CONTINUES THAT
TRADITION THERE'S BEEN RESEARCH
AROUND THE WORLD THAT'S PROVEN
CONCLUSIVELY THAT LEGISLATIVE
YOUR MARKS ARE NOT IN THE
PUBLIC'S BEST INTEREST IN FACT
WHAT'S BEST TO DO IS TO
ALLOCATE APPROPRIATE AMOUNTS OF
MONEY. TO EACH DEPARTMENT AND
WHAT THE DEPARTMENT IN A NON.
POLITICAL WAY DISTRIBUTE THAT
MONEY TO WHERE IT NEEDS TO GO
THIS IS NOT CONSISTENT. WITH A
PUBLIC GOOD PUBLIC POLICY ARE
IN A VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
OBERNOLTE MS MELENDEZ YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MY QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR. WITHOUT OBJECTION I'M
OKAY SO YOU SAID THE TEN
MILLION FOR SECURITY CONCERNS
ARE WHAT WHAT SECURITY CONCERNS
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT. THERE ARE
NOTED SECURITY CONCERNS THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS REGARDING THE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD FACILITIES
IN TERMS OF ATTACKS AS WELL AS-
A VARIETY OF. ACTUALLY.
CONCERNS THAT PEOPLE NOT ONLY
VISITORS BUT ALSO THE STAFF%
WERE FACING SAFETY ISSUES SO
THIS IS TEN MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S A PROPERTY FOR THOSE.
THAT. THIS MELENDEZ THANK YOU
SO WHEN WE HAVE THE BUDGET
HEARING YESTERDAY AND I ASKED
THIS QUESTION THERE SEEM TO BE
WELL THERE WEREN'T A WHOLE LOT
OF ANSWERS I UNDERSTAND THIS
WAS A PRIORITY THAT CAME FROM
THE SENATE. BUT THE LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL. I SAYS TO HELP HEALTH
CENTERS TO PROVIDE ABORTION
SERVICES IN MAY BE THE TARGETS
OF VIOLENCE AND VANDALISM IT
DOESN'T SAY THOUGH HOW THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO SPEND THE MONEY UP
25% CAN GO TOWARDS
ADMINISTRATIVE COST. IT'S VERY
BROAD AND VAGUE AND I'M ON I
JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY WE'RE
SENDING TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
FIND. PLANNED PARENTHOOD IT
DOESN'T EVEN HAVE TO GO FOR
SECURITY. THAT JUST SO I WOULD
URGE IN ABOUT. THANK YOU AS
WELL AS SAYING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. MR TAKING
MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU WISH. JUST
RESPECT. CAR CLUB OF THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL
TIED UP ICE FORTY EIGHT KNOWS
TEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES AND
THE MEDIA TRANSMETAL. TO THE
SENATE. WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE. SB ONE TWELVE. SENATE
BILL ONE TWELVE BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACCOLADE STATE
GOVERNMENT MAKING APPROPRIATION
OF FOUR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL A TO THE
BUDGET MISTER TECH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I SB ONE TWELVE HAS A
VARIETY OF TECHNICAL. CLEAN UPS.
FIRST AND FOREMOST OF RESTORES
THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S ABILITY. TO CONDUCT
DISCRETIONARY AUDITS ON THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
ADDITIONALLY IT ALLOWS
INDIVIDUAL CITED FOR A
VIOLATION OF VEHICLE EXHAUST
SYSTEM NOISE STANDARDS
GOVERNING TO FIX THE ISSUE
RATHER THAN BE SIGNED IT. WE
WITHOUT I RESPECT THAT'S FIVE
VOTE ON SB ONE TWELVE. THINGS
CHIANG MISTER OF ADULTERY
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION SB ONE TWELVE THIS
TRAILER BILL AN AXE A NUMBER OF
CHANGES TO THE STATE CODE
RELATED TO STATE GOVERNMENT BUT
AMONG THEM. IT ENABLES
TRANSFERS OF VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WERE MADE IN
PREVIOUS YEARS OUT OF THE
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT
THE B. S. A. N. INTO THE NEWLY
CREATED BUDGET DEFICIT SAVINGS
ACCOUNT THE B. D. S. A- AND
ALTHOUGH THESE TWO FUNDS HAVE
VERY SIMILAR NAMES. THEY WERE
CREATED IN VERY DISSIMILAR WAYS
AND THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
RESTRICTIONS THE B. D. S. A IT
WAS CREATED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND HAS NO RESTRICTIONS ON HOW
IT CAN BE USED THE B. S. A. WAS
KEY CREATED BY THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND IT HAS SOME
PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL RESTRICTIONS
ON HOW CAN BE USED AMONG THEM
THE FACT THAT THE GOVERNOR MUST
HAVE A FINDING A FISCAL
EMERGENCY BEFORE FUNDS MAY BE
TRANSFERRED. I BELIEVE THAT
UNABLE IN THE TRANSFER OF FUNDS
OUT OF A RESTRICTED ACCOUNT
INTO AN. UNRESTRICTED ACCOUNT
IS A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT
ARGENEAU VOTE. YEAH THANK YOU
MISTER OVER MULTI MEMBERS AS
KEEP THE VOLUME LEVEL
MANAGEABLE THE CHAMBER. WHEN WE
HEAR THESE BUDGET ITEMS SEEING
NO ADDITIONAL. DISCUSSION
MISTER CHENEY MAKE CLOTHES WE
WISH THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ON WITH ALL DUE RESPECT FOR MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BIG BEAR WOULD
BELIEVE THE MINOR TECHNICAL
MODIFICATIONS ON BOTH RESERVE
ACCOUNTS IS FULLY ONLINE WITH
ALLOWING THE STATE TO CONTINUE
TO SAVE A GREATER AMOUNT OF
MONEY SAVING FOR THE RAINY DAY
THAT WE DO KNOW IS COMING IN
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I BUILT ON THIS BE ONE TWELVE.
THANK YOU FOR STAYING WITH
ACCESSIBLE FOR THE ROLE. IT IS
OUT OF ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE
TO VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY NINE KNOWS
THIRTEEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES
AND IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO
THE SENATE. MEMBERS THIS IS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTEEN. THE
COURT AGREED SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTEEN BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACCOLADE HOUSING A
MAKING APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. MISTER
TECH. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
SB ONE THIRTEEN IS A HOUSING
CLEAN OF TRAILER BILL. THE
LARGEST ITEM IN THERE'S A
PROVIDES THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE NATIONAL MORTGAGE SPECIAL
DEPOSIT FUND YOUR CALL THAT
THIS WAS SETTLEMENT MONEY FROM
THE PREVIOUS ATTORNEY GENERAL
SUIT WITH ALL THE LENDERS
DURING THE FORECLOSURE CRISIS
THIS HOUSING TRUST FUND WILL BE
USED TO SERVICE TENANTS AS WELL
AS HOMEOWNERS AND WE DO GROUP
TO BELIEVE. THAT THIS WILL
HOPEFULLY RESOLVE THE LEGAL
ISSUE THAT WAS LITIGATED THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS IN ADDITION
PROVIDES A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO STUDY HOW TO ESTABLISH AND
MANAGE A TRUST. FOR THE
NATIONAL MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT IT
ALSO AUTHORIZES THE COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS OR FISCAL AGENT OF
A MULTI AGENCY WORKING GROUP TO
REQUEST FUNDING TO DEVELOP AND
ACCELERATE IMPLEMENTATION FOR
THE REGIONAL HOUSING NEED
ALLOCATION DOCUMENT OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS READ. AND WITHOUT A
RESPECT FOR US FOR I BUILT ON
SB ONE THIRTY. THANKS FOR
STAYING. THE TROUBLED MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE THIRTEEN IS THE CHAIR
MENTION THIS BILL CREATES A
TRUST TO RECEIVE THE FUNDING
FROM THE NATIONAL MORTGAGE
SETTLEMENT. THE STATE HAS WAGED
A MULTI YEAR EFFORT TO PREVENT
PAYING THIS MONEY OUT TO THE
BENEFICIARIES FOR WHOM IT WAS
INTENDED THOSE BEING. OF
MORTGAGE HOLDERS AND FISCAL
DISTRESS THAT ARE FACING TO
FORECLOSURE I AM BEYOND HAPPY
THAT WE ARE FINALLY GETTING
AROUND TO PUTTING THAT MONEY TO
THE USE IT WAS INTENDED.
HOWEVER I DO HAVE A CONCERN AND
ALTHOUGH I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BILL I WANTED TO RAISE IT HERE
AND THAT IS THAT THIS BILL ALSO
CONTAINS INTENT LANGUAGE. AS TO
HOW THOSE TRUST FUNDS WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED AND AMONG THE TEN
LANGUAGES SAYS THAT IT'S GOING
TO GO TO AID. HOMEOWNERS AND
WHO ARE FACING FORECLOSURE
WHICH IS APPROPRIATE BUT ALSO
SAYS THAT IT CAN BE DISTRIBUTED
FOR LEGAL AID TO RENTERS AND
ALTHOUGH THAT MIGHT BE A WORTHY
CAUSE. THAT IS NOT AMONGST THE
USES TO WHICH THE ORIGINAL
SUBTLE AGREEMENT SAID THAT IT
COULD BE PUT SO WE HAVE JUST
FINISHED SPENDING MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER
MONEY. ON THIS FRUITLESS
LAWSUIT TO PREVENT PAYING THIS
MONEY I WOULD HATE FOR US TO
WIND UP IN COURT AGAIN WHICH IS
WHAT I FEAR WILL HAPPEN. IF WE
TRY TO USE THIS MONEY FOR A
PURPOSE FOR WHICH IT WAS NOT
INTENDED ON THE RIDDLE
SETTLEMENT BUT HAVING SAID THAT
I. ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE ON SB
ONE FIFTEEN. THERE WAS
OBERNOLTE SAYING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE STIR TING
YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. ABSOLUTELY
WE REALLY RESPECT THE FEEDBACK
FROM MY COLLEAGUE REGARDING
THE- MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT WE
HEARD FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT THEY DO BELIEVE. BASED ON
THERE A LOOK OF THE SETTLEMENT
THAT. THE MONEY FOR TENANTS AS
WELL AS HOMEOWNERS DOES
QUALIFY. BUT AGAIN WILL BE
MAKING SURE AND LOOKING MUCH
CLOSELY. THROUGH OUR BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT DOES. SATISFIED THE.
ACTUAL SADDAM. WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK MICHAEL. THEY
ARE STAYING AT THAT THE CLERK
WILL UP THE WRONG. NUMBERS. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
DESIRE VOTE. CLARK WELL THOSE
ARE ALL TALLY THE BUT I SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO
THE SENATE. YEAH. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
PRECISION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES
WILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAM TO
TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING BILLS
WITHOUT REFERENCE FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE AB.
1-511-511-8120 ONE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT REQUEST IS
GRANTED. WITHOUT REFERENCE THE
FILE. AB ONE FOURTEEN. CLICK
RIGHT. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FOURTEEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET ACCOLADE EDUCATION
FINANCE A MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET MISTER CAN YOU
MAKE IT OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB ONE FOURTEEN IS OUR
EDUCATION CLEAN UP BILL IT
EXTENDS THE ETHNIC STUDIES
MODEL CURRICULUM DEADLINES BY
ONE YEAR ALLOWING THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO MAKE
NECESSARY REVISIONS IT ALSO
PROVIDES CHANGES TO THE
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL IN THE SUMMER
SYSTEMS PROGRAM. MAKES GENERAL
FUND IN FEDERAL FUNDS FOR THE
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM IN
THE EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
WORK FORCE GRANT PROGRAM AMENDS
THE NEW COLLEGE SAVINGS PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE
SCHOLARSHIPBOARD RECORD FOR
THE OPEN COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS. FOR ALL BABIES WHEN
IN JULY. BABIES BORN AFTER JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY IT ALSO
MAKES A ADDITIONAL TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO K. TWELVE
AND HIGHER EDUCATION. I WITHOUT
RESPECT FOR US RIGHT. THEY
MISSED A MEASURE OF AN OLDIE
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE FOURTEEN THIS
TRAILER BILL APPROPRIATES FUNDS
TO AID IN IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
EDUCATIONAL PORTION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET. THESE CHANGES ARE
LARGELY SUPPORTABLE ARJUN AYE. THANK YOU MISTER OVER
DON'T THINK SEE NOTATIONAL
DISCUSSION OF THE ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBER
SERVICE OUT OF A- CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL EYES SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN THE MEDIA
TRANSMETAL TWO ENGROSSING AND
ROLLING. WITHOUT REFERENCE THE
FILE AB ONE FIFTEEN CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FIFTEEN
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
ACCOLADE MEDI CAL MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. MR TANK THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB ONE
FIFTEEN IS A BILL THAT RE
AUTHORIZES ATTACKS ON MANAGED
CARE ORGANIZATIONS BUT UNLIKE
MANY OTHER TAX IS A TAX THAT'S
FULLY SUPPORTED BY OUR HEALTH
PLANS HOPEFULLY YOU'VE ALL SEEN
THE LETTERS SO ISSUING THEIR
SUPPORT AND THE REASON THAT IS
IT ALLOWS US TO DOUBLE THE
REVENUE THAT WE GET FROM THIS
TAX. FROM FEDERAL MEDICAID
DOLLARS AND USE IT TO SUPPORT
OUR LOCAL MEDICAID PROGRAM SO
THEREFORE THE NEW TAXES
ESTIMATED TO RESULT IN A
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS IS
SCHEDULED FOR THE SAVINGS OF
OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS
RESOURCES THAT WILL BE SORELY
NEEDED TO REALLY SUPPORT. OUR
HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS. AGAIN.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
MEMBERS WHO WERE HERE. IN THE
PREVIOUS YEARS WERE WE
ACTUALLY. DID DO THE MCO TAX
THIS IS JUST A RENEWAL OF THAT
PREVIOUS PROPOSAL THIS ALLOW US
UP TO ASK THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. FOR THAT AUTHORITY
AGAIN WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON AB ONE
FIFTEEN. THANK YOU MISTER
MISTER OVER MULTI MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB ONE FIFTEEN I'M SURE
EVERYONE IN THE CHAMBERS AWARE
OF HOW THESE TAXES ON MANAGEDCARE ORGANIZATIONS WORK. WE
IMPOSE A TAX ON POLICIES THAT
IS MOST HEAVILY TARGETED AT
MEDI CAL INSURANCE PLANS AND
BECAUSE OF THE STATE ONLY PAYS
HALF OF THOSE PREMIUMS IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PAYS THE
OTHER HALF. THAT RESULTS IN NET
REVENUE TO THE STATE GENERAL
FUND AND IS THE CHAIR SAID
THAT'S GOING TO BE A JUST UNDER
TWO BILLION DOLLARS OF REVENUE
A YEAR. HOWEVER IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THERE IS NO SUCH
THING AS A FREE TAX AND
ALTHOUGH THIS WILL RESULT. IN A
STATE BUDGET SURPLUS THAT IS
TWO BILLION DOLLARS HIGHER IT
WILL ALSO REDUCE IN A FIT RICH
RESULT IN A FEDERAL BUDGET
DEFICIT THAT IS TWO BILLION
DOLLARS HIGHER. I ALSO AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY FEDERAL LAW
PREVENTS US FROM SPECIFICALLY
TARGETING MEDI CAL INSURANCE
PLANS SO THE TAX HAS TO BE
APPLIED MORE BROADLY AND THAT'S
GOING TO RESULT. IN AN
UNREIMBURSED TAX LIABILITY
BETWEEN SIXTEEN AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR THAT
WILL BE BORNE. BY THE POLICY
HOLDERS OF COMMERCIAL POLICIES
IN THE FORM OF HIGHER HEALTH
INSURANCE PREMIUMS ON THOSE
POLICIES NOW WHEN WE ENACTED
THIS TAX SEVERAL YEARS AGO. WE
ENACTED ALSO CONTEMPORARY DAIS
CHANGES TO THE STATE CORPORATE
TAX CODE THAT WOULD RESULT IN
SAVINGS ON THOSE SAME POLICIES
IN A WAY. IN A IN A ATTEMPT TO
HOLD THOSE POLICY HOLDERS
HARMLESS I AM VERY DISAPPOINTED
THAT THAT WAS NOT DONE THIS
YEAR SO THOSE POLICY HOLDERS
ARE GOING TO BEAR THE BRUNT. OF
THAT ADDITIONAL UNREIMBURSED.
TAX LIABILITY FOR THOSE REASONS
I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER OBERNOLTE SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM MISTER TING YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MY FOR MUCH JUST TO
CLARIFY MY COLLEAGUES COMMENTS
YES. THERE WILL BE AN INCREASE
IN MONTHLY PREMIUMS THE
ESTIMATE. IS ABOUT FIVE TO TEN
CENTS. INCREASE ON EACH OF
THOSE MONTHLY PREMIUMS SO
AGAIN. FOR A VERY VERY SMALL
INCREASE WE'RE GONNA GET TWO
BILLION DOLLARS A BENEFIT THAT
ARE REALLY GIVE US MUCH CLOSER.
TO UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE THE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN REALLY
OFFER THE KIND OF HEALTH CARE.
THAT WE WANT. FOR OUR CITIZENS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
RESPECT FOR YES FIVE. THEY WERE
STAYING WITH THAT THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. MEMBERS
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR. THIS
TAKES FIFTY FOUR
. MISTER KING
MOVES A CALL
. MEMBERS WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE. THIS IS AB
ONE EIGHTEEN CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTEEN BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
NATURALLY THE STATE EMPLOYMENT
MAKING A PROBATIONER FOR TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. MISTER
TECH. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB ONE EIGHTEEN BUDGET TRAILER
BILL WHICH PROVIDES LEGISLATIVE
RATIFICATION OF THE MEMORANDUMS
OF UNDERSTANDING. AGREE TO BY
THE STATE AND BARGAINING UNITS
ONE. 545-711-1314 FIFTEEN
SEVENTEEN TWENTY. AND TWENTY
ONE. A SPECIFICALLY JUST TO
TELL YOU BARGAIN UNIT TO HEAR
OUR CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES AND
HEARING OFFICERS A STATE
EMPLOYMENT. BARGAIN YOU TO FIVE
IS THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HIGHWAY PATROLMAN. PARKING IS
SEVEN IS PROTECTIVE SERVICES
THE PUBLIC SAFETY OTHERWISE
REPRESENTED BY C. S. ELLIE A-
BARGAIN YOU TO THIRTEEN IS
STATIONARY ENGINEERS. ARE
BARKING UNITS. 1-341-114-1570
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ARE ALL UPSET
ABOUT YES YEAH. THE BILL
PROBABLY TO HUNT FORTY TWO
MILLION. FIFTY OF WHICH IS FROM
THE GENERAL FUND FROM VARIOUS
SOURCES FOR PLAY COMPENSATION.
IT DID ADDITION TO FOR YOUR
BUDGETARY NUMBERS FOR SEIU
BARGAINING UNITS FIVE SEVEN OF
THIRTEEN ARE. FOUR POINT NINE
DIED. WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A. MR OF ANTI THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE EIGHTEEN AS A
CHAIR MENTIONED THIS TRAILER
BILL RATIFIES NEW MEMORANDUMS
OF UNDERSTANDING WITH THIRTEEN
DIFFERENT STATE EMPLOYEE
BARGAINING UNITS. THAT GRANTS
THEM GENERAL SORRY FUND
INCREASES OF BETWEEN TWO AND A
QUARTER IN THREE POINT 75% PER
YEAR THESE ARE IN LINE WITH
INFLATION AND THEREFORE THESE
MO USE ARE SUPPORTABLE. HOWEVER
I HAVE TO RAISE A CONCERN OF
THAT I HAVE WITH THE BARGAINING
PROCESS THIS YEAR. STATE LAW
REQUIRES THAT COMPENSATION
STUDIES BE DONE BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BEFORE
SITTING DOWN WITH THE
BARGAINING UNITS TO NEGOTIATE
THE AMMO USE AND ALTHOUGH THIS
WAS DONE THIS YEAR THE AMMO
USED DO NOT APPEAR TO REFLECT
THE RESULTS OF THE COMPENSATION
STUDIES. IN SOME CATION THOSE
COMPENSATION STUDIES INDICATED
THAT JOB CLASSIFICATIONS WERE
UNDER COMPENSATED IN SOME THEY
INDICATED THAT THEY WERE OVER
COMPENSATED HOWEVER THESE
CLASSIFICATIONS WERE ALL
ASSIGNED TO THE SAME MODEST
GENERAL CELL INCREASES AS ALL
THE REST. OF THE
CLASSIFICATIONS IN THEIR
BARGAINING UNITS SO OBVIOUSLY
IF WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT TAKE
THE TIME AND GO TO THE TROUBLE
OF DOING THAT THESE
CLASSIFICATION SURVEYS WE
SHOULD TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT
WHEN WE NEGOTIATE THE MO USE.
SO I AM IN HOPES THAT THAT WILL
HAPPEN THE NEXT TIME TO DO OF
SITS. DOWN BUT ARE THESE ARE
MORE USER SUPPORTABLE IRISH AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL SEE. SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM MISTER TING YOU MAY CLOSE
WE WISH. THANK YOU FOR SPEAKER
OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIG BEAR'S
COMMENTS ARE VERY WELL TAKEN WE
SHOULD DEFINITELY BE. LOOKING
AT THOSE ISSUES NEXT YEAR WE
HAVE MORE AND MORE USED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE- COMPOSITION
STUDIES ARE BEING LOOKED AT AND
ON OUR BEING. FACTORED. IN WHEN
THERE IS AN AND ARE YOU SO
WITHOUT A RESPECT FAST FIVE.
AND WITHOUT FOR GLOBAL ROLE
MEMBERS. CULTURAL TALLY THE
VOTE AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO
ENGROSSING AND IN ROLLING
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE THIS
IS AB ONE TWENTY ONE. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE TWENTY ONE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET ACCOLADE A
SOCIAL SERVICES A MAKING
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY PER RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. YOU'RE TAKING
YOU MAY GET OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS OUR
HUMAN SERVICES CLEAN UP TRAILER
BILL. CLARIFIES A TWELVE MONTH
CONTINUOUS ELIGIBILITY FOR CAL
WORKS STAGE ONE CHILD CARE THAT
WAS IN THE JUNE BUDGET. ALSO
UPDATES AND STREAMLINES
LANGUAGE REGARDING THE NOTICING
FOR CHILD CARE SERVICES.
WITHOUT A RESPECT FOR YOUR EYES
PRIVATE. THINGS TING MATURE
OVERALL THE MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
TWENTY ONE AS A CHAIR MENTION
THIS TRAILER BILL IMPLEMENTS
CODE CLEAN UP. TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
200-019-2000 TWENTY STATE
BUDGET. THESE CHANGES ARE
LARGELY SUPPORTABLE THIS
CONCLUDES THE FILLING J. CHAU
ARJUN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER OBERNOLTE SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS SO
DESIRED ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF.
IT IS OUT OF THE CLERK WELL
CLOSER ROLE. TELL YOU VOTE I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO
ENGROSSING. AND ROLLING
. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE I'M NINETY FOUR SB SIX
SIXTY EIGHT RUBIO TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. THE CLERK WILL
NOTE. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
BE TAKING UP CONCURRENCE ITEMS.
THESE ARE CONCURRENCE ITEMS
BEGINNING WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO. THIS IS A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER DAVID CHIU
ANOTHER SNACK LATER HOUSING. MR
CHIU YOU MAIL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER CALLING SOME
CONCURRENCE A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN IS A REGIONAL SELF
HELP BILL TO ADDRESS A HOUSING
CRISIS IN THE BAY AREA GIVEN
THE NINE COUNTY REGION THE
AUTHORITY TO CONSIDER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDING
SIMILAR TO HOW THE REGION HAS
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY TO RAISE
MONIES FOR TRANSPORTATION. AND
SAN FRANCISCO BAY RESTORATION
SENTIMENTS WERE CRAFTED WITH
SIGNIFICANT INPUT BY BAY AREA
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDING
WITHOUT CREATING A NEW
BUREAUCRACY AND SURE THAT MOST
FUNDS GO DIRECTLY TO COUNTIES
AND CITIES ARE CAPABLE SPENDING
THAT. AND PROVIDE THE RIGHT
ARRAY OF FUNDRAISING TOOLS FOR
THE REGION WANT TO THANK BOTH
BAY AREA REGIONAL BODIES OF
VOTED OVERWHELMINGLY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AS AMENDED AND WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR CHIU MS
BAUER K. HANNYA RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
RISE IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. I
DIDN'T OPPOSE THE BILL WHEN IT
WAS IN OUR HOUSE THE FIRST TIME
BECAUSE I WAS IN. GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN THIS TAX
MEASURE GOES ON TARA BALLOT
THAT ALL THE CITIES IN THE
REGION. BENEFITS THERE'S A
RETURN OF THOSE TAX DOLLARS TO
OUR TAX PAYERS. AND DESPITE ALL
THE WORK AND AFTER WENT THROUGH
THE TWO BODIES WHICH LIKE THE
AUTHOR SAID SUPPORTED IT. I'M
AT THIS POINT THE PROPONENTS OF
THE BILL ARE. FORTHCOMING THAT
THE FUNDS WILL OF MY
CONSTITUENTS WILL PAY THESE
TAXES. AND THEY WILL SEE NO
RETURN OF THAT INVESTMENT IN
THEIR CITIES. IN EACH OF OUR
CITIES WILL CONTINUE TO GET
RAIN ALLOCATIONS. BUT THE
LARGER CITIES WILL GET A RETURN
ON THOSE FUNDS AND THE SMALLER
CITIES WILL NOT. AND WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO TAX OUR
CONSTITUENTS. UNLESS WE MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS OVERSIGHT
THERE IS ACCOUNTABILITY AND OUR
CONSTITUENCY RETURN ON THE
INVESTMENT IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
WHICH THIS BIT THIS MEASURE
WILL NOT DO IT WILL ENSURE THAT
THE SMALL CITIES I REPRESENTS
THE NO RETURN ON THOSE DOLLARS.
AND SO I REGRETFULLY HAVE TO
OPPOSE IT. DAVIS BACK A HAND.
MS WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IT
REFLECTS THE COLLABORATION
BETWEEN LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
AND US AND I KNOW THE MAYORS
OF. TO MY CITIES OAKLAND AND
BERKELEY ARE DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
MAKING SURE THAT THIS BILL
WORKED FOR THESE CITIES. I'M
EVEN THOSE WITHOUT A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP WITH EVEN THOSE
WITHOUT A GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH THEIR COUNTIES OR WITHOUT
A HUGE JOB BASE. BOTH REGIONAL
BODIES GOT TO SHAPE AND THEN
VOTE ON THE MEASURE. AND IT'S
SO OVERWHELMINGLY INCLUDING A
TWENTY THREE TO THREE VOTE AT
THE ASSOCIATION ASSOCIATION OF
BAY AREA GOVERNMENTS WHICH
REPRESENTS. THE SMALLER CITIES.
AND THE COUNTIES IN THE REGION
SAID RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WICKS
MINS MELENDEZ YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
LEASING JOHN I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM DISTRICTS
SIXTEEN THIS THIS BILL IS GOING
TO ALLOW I'VE GOT A LIST HERE
OF ALL THE TAXES LET'S SEE AN
AUTHORIZES THE FOLLOWING TAXES
ACROSS NINE DIFFERENT COUNTY TO
PAY FOR MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ON THE SPECIAL TAXES INCLUDING
PARTIAL TAXES GROSS RECEIPTS
SPECIAL BUSINESS TAXES LIKE THE
HEAD TAX COMMERCIAL LINKAGE
BEES. AND IT'S GOING TO ALLOW
WHAT FROM WHAT I CAN SEE TAXES
RAISED IN DUBLIN DANVILLE
LAFAYETTE TO BE SPENT IN URBAN
SAN FRANCISCO SO SHE MAKES A
VERY VALID POINT THAT NOT
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO BENEFIT
FROM THIS TAX AND IF YOU THINK
THAT. THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE A
TEMPLATE FOR YOUR DISTRICT THEN
YOU'RE NOT PAYING ATTENTION
BECAUSE IT EXACTLY WHAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE SO I WOULD CAUTION
YOU. TO LOOK AT THIS YOU MAY
SEE THIS AS JUST SORT OF A
DISTRICT BELL BUT IT'S GOING TO
BE COMING TO A DISTRICT NEAR
YOU. IF YOU IF YOU VOTE FOR
THIS BILL AND ALLOW IT TO
FLOURISH I WOULD URGE YOU KNOW
ABOUT. MR GRAYSON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE. IF I MAKE WITHOUT
OBJECTION LIST AUTHOR OF. JUST
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS BASED ON
SOME THINGS CONCERNS THAT I
ALSO SHARED WHEN THIS BILL
FIRST CAME OUT AND THEN ALSO
WORKED WITH WITH YOU AND YOUR
STAFF ON I DO WANT TO
CLARIFICATION AS FAR AS A
RETURN TO SOURCE THAT WAS A
VERY SERIOUS AND IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO ME BEING FROM THE EAST
BAY AND I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT YOU DID WORK INTO YOUR
BILL A RETURN TO SOURCE.
PRINCIPLE OR OR PARTY YOUR BILL
ABSOLUTELY AND I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT BECAUSE I THINK WE
HAD A LITTLE BIT OF A
MISUNDERSTANDING SO WE AMENDED
THE BILL SO THAT 80% OF THE
FUNDS RAISED BY ANY COUNTY WILL
GO BACK TO THAT COUNTY BECAUSE
OF THE VERY CONCERNED THAT WE
HAVE HEARD. FROM A NUMBER OF
FOLKS SO WANT TO JUST MAKE THAT
VERY CLEAR ON THIS BILL ALSO
ALLOWS ANY COUNTY TO OPT OUT OF
BEING PART OF A NINE COUNTY BAY
AREA FUNDING MECHANISM SO IF
IT'S PROPOSED ANY COUNTY
INCLUDING YOURS CAN DECIDE THAT
THEY DO NOT WANT TO PARTICIPATE
SO THAT THEY WOULD NOT
PARTICIPATE IN EITHER THE
RAISING OF NEW REVENUES. OR THE
DISPERSED. OF THOSE NEW
REVENUES. MR RACING YEAH ONE
MORE QUESTION IF POSSIBLE IN
THAT. CASE AND THIS IS ONLY A
RESTORATION. IS GENERALLY DO
NOT OKAY THANK YOU COLLOQUY. MR
CHIU MAY EMPLOY FIVE HIS
REMARKS. TO ADDRESS ANY ANIMAL
I'M HAPPY OF MR GRISSOM LIKE TO
ASK A QUESTION THROUGH THE
SPEAKER. IF YOU LIKE TO DO
THAT. MISS RACING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT THIS IS A BILL
THAT WOULD THE. HE CAN.
ADDRESSES IN CLOSING REMARKS
THIS BILL IS SIMPLY OF. A WAY
TO PUT THE- THE VOTE TO THE
VOTERS OR PUT THE MEASURE TO
THE VOTERS IS AS FAR AS A TAX
AND THAT WE'RE NOT ACTUALLY
VOTING ON THE TAX TODAY. THE
RESTORATION MISTER CHIU MAY
ADDRESS THAT IN HIS CLOTHES WE
HAVE ONGOING DEBATE MISTER
KALRA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS A
REALLY IMPORTANT MEASURE FOR IT
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB PORCINI
SEVEN. TO SAY THE BAY AREA'S
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE SOME OF THE
SIGNIFICANT HOUSING CRISIS. IS
A SEVERE UNDERSTATEMENT THE
REALITY IS THAT THE SHORTFALL
AND OF THE- AFFECTS OF THAT ARE
FELT IN EVERY CORNER. OF THE
BAY AREA SAN JOSE MEASURE AREA
DOES NOT THE MOST EXPENSIVE
HOUSING MARKET IN THE NATION
WITH MEDIAN HOME PRICES AT OVER
ONE POINT TWO MILLION. DOLLARS
A HOME. NOW WE KNOW THAT WHEN
IT COMES TO THE HOUSING CRISIS
EVEN WE TALK REGIONALLY IT'S
NOT ABOUT JUST WHAT ONE CITY
DOES IT HAS TO BE TREATED AS A
REGIONAL ISSUE. I SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE ALLOWS A LOCAL
CONTROL LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
DECIDE LOCALVOTERS TO DECIDE
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS TO WORK
TOGETHER ON REGIONAL BOARDS TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE CONTINUING TO
BUILD HOUSING BECAUSE- AS WE
HEARD YESTERDAY. DURING THE
DEBATE EVERYONE SEEMS TO AGREE
THAT WE NEED TO START BUILDING
MORE HOUSING THIS IS AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL FOR US TO IS TO
DO THAT EVEN MORE SO THAN WE'VE
ALREADY BEEN DOING. AND FRANKLY
WHEN SAN JOSE BILLS AND SAM
CISCO BILLS THAT DOESN'T JUST
HELP SAN JOSE AND SAN FRANCISCO
IT HELPS ALL JURISDICTIONS
ESPECIALLY THOSE JURISDICTIONS
BUT REFUSED TO BUILD THEY ALSO
BENEFIT WHAT OTHER CITIES BUILD
AND SO I URGE. COLLEAGUES TO
ALLOW OUR LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS THE TOOLS NECESSARY
TO DEAL. WITH THE MOST SEVERE
HOPPING CRISIS IN THE NATION.
THANK YOU MUCH KALRA SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ADAM MISTER CHU YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
SEVEN REYES AND SALAMI ANSWER
THE QUESTION FROM A COLLEAGUE
FROM CONCORD. SO THE WAY THIS%
PROCESS WORKS IS AS WE HAVE
DONE IS A REGION. IN THE BAY
AREA WHEN IT COMES TO
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING AS WE'VE
DONE FOR BAY AREA RESTORATION.
WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON TODAY'S TO
AUTHORIZE THE POSSIBILITY THAT
THE BAY AREA REGION COULD
CONSIDER REVENUE MEASURES THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE TO GET APPROVAL
FOR JUST PUT ON THE BALLOT.
THEY HAVE TO GET APPROVAL FOR
IT NOT JUST BY ONE BUT ACTUALLY
TO REGIONAL BODIES IN THE BAY
AREA. THE WAY IT WOULD WORK IS
THERE'S ONE REGIONAL BODY THAT
IS COMMONLY KNOWN AS BEING
REPRESENTED MORE HIGHLY BY.
SMALLER SUBURBAN CITIES OF THE
TYPE THAT YOU REPRESENT AND OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM AROUND A
REPRESENTS. THAT IS A BACK
THERE'S ANOTHER BODY M. T. C.
THAT IS TYPICALLY VIEWED AS
BEING A BIT MORE DOMINATED BY
THE LARGER CITIES. BOTH BODIES
WOULD HAVE TO AGREE IN THE WAY
THE PROCESS WORKS IS. A BAG.
WHICH IS VIEWED AS A BIT MORE
DOMINANT BY AGAIN SMALLER
SUBURBAN CITIES. THEY WOULD BE
THE FIRST. INSTITUTION AS YOU
WILL TO PUT A PLAN TOGETHER. I
THEY WOULD PROPOSE THE PLAN IF
THE MTC AGREES WITH IT. I THEN
THAT WOULD BE THE PLAN THAT THE
VOTERS WITHIN CONSIDER IF THE
MTC CHANGES THAT IN ANY WAY IT
GOES BACK TO A BACK FOR
APPROVAL. SO A BAG GETS THE
FIRST WORD AND THE LAST WORD
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
HEAVILY NEGOTIATED. WITH MANY
OF THE SMALLER VERTICALLY EAST
BAY CITIES THAT ARE BEING
REPRESENTED TODAY. SO I JUST
WANTED TO STATE THAT AGAIN
THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT OF
APPROVAL THAT WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS AND LET ME JUST CLOSE BY
SAYING. THIS IS A MEASURE TO
ENSURE THAT THE BAY AREA WHICH
HAS BEEN THE EPICENTER OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE CAN HELP
OURSELVES. IN BEING ABLE TO
RAISE A FOUR WHEEL HOUSING
FUNDS AND HOPEFULLY THAT'LL
MEAN THAT WE WILL AS A REGION.
OUT REQUIRE LESS FUNDING FROM
THE OVERALL GENERAL FUND WHICH
SHOULD IN YOUR TO THE BENEFIT
OF EVERY. ONE OF THE STATE SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THEY WERE
ISSUE WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN
THE- THESE ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS LETTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOSE
.
MISSION HUMANS CALL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE. AB TWO
FIFTY THREE. THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIFTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER MARK
STONE AN ACCOLADE COURTS MR
STONE YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES A REMOTE CORE
PORTER PILOT IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY ASK FOR YOUR CONCURRENCE
AND SENATE AMENDMENTS. SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARPOOL OF THE WRONG. HEADED
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
OUR DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIE VOTE I SIXTY
EIGHT. NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FOR. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR IS AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY
COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
TWENTY BY THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY AN ACCOLADE A
PERSONAL RIGHTS MR STONE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THIS BILL IS AN EXAMPLE OF OUR
CHECKS AND BALANCES OBLIGATION
UNDER THE DOCTRINE OF
SEPARATION OF POWERS. AND IF
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
CAN GOOGLE IT. THERE IS A CASE
A CAME UP FAIRLY RECENTLY. THAT
IDENTIFIED A PROBLEM THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR. HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT HAS HAD EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAVE STATUTORY AUTHORITY.
TO BE ABLE TO SUE ON FEDERAL
NONDISCRIMINATION LAWS IN
FEDERAL COURT GENERAL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THOSE
FEDERAL NONDISCRIMINATION LAWS
ALLOW STATES TO SUE IN FEDERAL
COURT. THERE WAS A CASE THAT
CAME DOWN RECENTLY THAT SAID
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR HOUSING
AND EMPLOYMENT COULD NOT SUE BE
BECAUSE IT NEEDED SPECIFIC
AUTHORITY TO DO SO THIS BILL
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM AND I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER STONE SENIOR DISCLOSURE
BAKER WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TELL A
VOTE I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM FIVE. AB FOR ONE
FOR THE COVERAGE. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR FOURTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER
BONTA AN ACCOLADE TO HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE MR BONTA THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A
BEFORE ONE FOUR IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AFTER TAKING
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE THAT
TURNED INTO A REPORTING BILL
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SIGNAL DISCLOSURE OF A
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
LETTERS AT ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
OF DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT EYES FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM SIX
AB SEVEN FIFTEEN COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTEEN BY
SIMPLY MEMBERS AREA THAN OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE PARKINSON'S DISEASE
MR NECESSARY AND YOU MAIL BUT-
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN ONE FIVE
WOULD SIMPLY EXTEND THE CAL THE
CALIFORNIA'S PARKINSON'S
DISEASE REGISTRY SUNSET FROM
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THE
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND WOULD LIKE
TO THANK MY WONDERFUL COLLEAGUE
FROM FRESNO. FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN SEEM
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CARPOOL OF
THE ROLE. DESIRE THAT ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
WELL CLOSE ROLE TIE BUT I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR
JONES SAWYER THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY RULE FOURTEEN
FIFTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JONES SAWYER IMMACULATELY
JUVENILES AND MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR MISTER JONES
SAWYER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB FORTY FIFTY FOURTH BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AFTER BEING AMENDED
IN THE SENATE TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE YOUTH
REINVESTMENT GRANT PROGRAM.
THAT WE AT THE LEGISLATURE
FUNDED IN THE BUDGET FOR THE
LAST TWO YEARS THIS BILL
INCLUDES A NUMBER OF TECHNICAL
FIXES THAT MAKE IT EASIER FOR
JURISDICTION TO APPLY FOR
GRANTS THE CHANGES ARE
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT THESE
FUNDS REACH EVERY PART OF THE
STATE KEEPING OUR USE OUT OF
THE PRISON SYSTEM AND
CONNECTING THEM TO SUPPORT OF
SERVICES IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE BOAT. THANK YOU RESTAURANTS
WHERE SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
OR GLOBAL ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THESE ARE VOTE ON MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF A CAR WELL. LOW'S
ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM EIGHT.
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
EIGHTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER JONES
SAWYER ACCOLADE A PLEA
BARGAINS. MR JOHNSON WHERE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
I PRESENT AB SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN
WHICH WAS AMENDED IN THE SENATE
TO SIMPLY CLARIFY EXISTING LAW
AND CODIFY APPELLATE COURT
CASES REGARDING PLEA BARGAINS.
THIS IS A REASONABLE CHANGE
THAT PRESERVE THE INTEGRITY OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS NATURE
TO CHANGES MADE IN STATE LAW BY
THIS BODY OR THE VOTERS ARE NOT
CIRCUMVENT IT ARE YOU SIR BY
LOCAL PROSECUTORS. THIS BILL
PASSED THE SENATE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AS WELL AS
THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK LIBERAL. WE DECIDED THAT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A-
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT
EYES FIFTY NINE. NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM NINE AB ELEVEN NINETY
ONE CLERK READ ASSEMBLY RULE
ELEVEN NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA ANOTHER'S AND
ACCOLADES THE GRANT PUBLIC
TRUST LANDS OF THE CITY OF
OAKLAND. MR BONTA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE AFTER
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN IN THE
SENATE THAT KEY STAKEHOLDERS
AGREE TO. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. FAMOUS BONTA
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE. DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLE. BUT I
FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TEN AB SEVEN FIFTY
NINE. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE A
TRAFFIC SAFETY MR BIGELOW THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB SEVEN
FIFTY NINE REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION TO
UPDATE THEIR GUIDANCE TO
SPECIFY APPROPRIATE AND
POSITIVE PROTECTION MEASURES
THEY CAN USE TO HELP ISOLATE
WORKERS OR WORK ZONES FROM
TRAFFIC. WITHOUT I ENCOURAGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOUSIR SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS THERE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM
ELEVEN IS AB EIGHT THIRTY THREE
COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
THIRTY THREE BY SOME REMEMBER
LACKEY AN ACCOLADE OF VEHICLES
IN THE CLEARLY YOUR TO SEE
THERE ARE. SIGNIFICANT MEDIALLY.
MR LACKEY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES TODAY
PROUD TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
THIRTY THREE WHICH CLARIFIES
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE MONTHLY PARKING CITATION
PAYMENT PLAN CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THIS BILL TOOK AN URGENCY
AMENDMENT AND THE SENATE AND I
URGENTLY REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER LACKEY SEE NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THIS
TAKES FIFTY FOUR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
KIRK WELL CLOSER ALL TELL YOU
WHAT I SIXTY NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY I SIXTY KNOWS HERE ON
THE MEASURE. SENATE AMENDMENTS
PARKING HEARD IN. FILE ITEM
TWELVE. AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
INSURANCE DECLARE THEIR TO SEE
THEIR UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY MR DAILY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS
BILL CONTAINS THREE PROVISIONS
TO SUPPORT HOMEOWNERS IN THE
INSURANCE MARKET. IN OUR STATE.
FIRST IT INCREASES THE LIMITS
FOR A HOMEOWNER'S INSURANCE
CLAIM HANDLED BY THE CALIFORNIA
INSURANCE GUARANTY ASSOCIATION.
SECOND IT INCREASES THE NUMBER
OF POLICIES A QUALIFY FOR
ENSURE RIGHT OUT CREDITS IN THE
FAIR PLAN. AND THIRD IT
INCREASES THE MINIMUM NOTICE
PERIOD FOR A NON RENEWAL OF A
HOMEOWNER'S INSURANCE POLICY
FROM FORTY FIVE TO SEVENTY FIVE
DAYS. THESE CHANGES PROVIDE
TANGIBLE NEAR TERM BENEFITS TO
HOMEOWNERS. IN WHAT FOR MANY
HAS BECOME A CHALLENGING
INSURANCE MARKET. THIS BILL
PASSED THE SENATE ON UNANIMOUS
FORTY TO ZERO VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
MISS DALY. SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE I'M SORRY MR VOEPEL. I
SUPPORT A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN
AS A THIRTY NINE YEAR INSURANCE
BROKER INSURANCE AGENT. WHAT
THIS BILL WILL DO WILL GIVE THE
BROKERS AND AGENTS EXTER TIME
TO SHOP OUT OTHER COVERAGE AND
THAT'S ESSENTIAL THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL. SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ADAM. SEVERAL OF THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLARK
WELL CLOSER ALL TALLY THE VOTE
EYES FIFTY NINE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY EYES FIFTY NINE KNOWS
HERE ON THE MEASURE. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTEEN. AB
THIRTEEN OH THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN OH THREE BY SOME
REMEMBER O'DONNELL AN ACCOLADE
SCHOOL FACILITIES MR O'DONNELL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
FIFTY NO THREE EXTENDS A SUNSET
ON A SCHOOL DISTRICT AUTHORITY
TO ASSESS THE FEES FOR THE USE
OF RECREATIONAL SPACE FROM
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. EXCESSIVE WEAR AND TEAR
RESULT IN INCREASED COSTS TO
MAINTAIN AND REPAIR GROUNDS
THAT INCREASES LIABILITY SHOULD
INJURIES OCCUR THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICT TO SHARE
FACILITIES FOR COMMUNITY USE
WHILE ENSURING SAFETY FOR ALL
USERS I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CAR
CLUB RURAL. BUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE. CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN IS AB TWENTY
THREE THE COURT AGREED SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY THREE BY SOME
MEMBER BURKE AN ACCOLADE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THIS BURKE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY THREE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
ESTABLISH A UNIT RATHER THAN A
DIRECTOR OF BUSINESS WORKFORCE
CORONATION. APPLIED THE UNIT TO
BUSINESS GENERALLY RATHER THAN
TO JUST SMALL BUSINESS AND
CLARIFIED FURTHER COOPERATION
WITH OTHER WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ENTITIES IN THE
STATE TO AVOID DUPLICATING
ACTIONS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS BURKE
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK LIBERAL. MEMBERS
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
EYES FIFTY EIGHT. NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. WE
HAVE REFERRED FILE ITEMS
FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN. WE WILL
PASS TO I'M SORRY WE WILL TAKE
UP FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN. AB TWO
EIGHTY THREE KERKORIAN ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KANSEN CHU AN
ACCOLADE CAL WORKS MR CHIU
EMAIL BUT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWO EIGHTY THREE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THE SENATE
THE MA'AM AND OUR TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE AND ROUTE
AND ROUTE PRETTY MUCH REMOVE
ALL OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR ARRIVAL. THING IS
CHOOSING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
LOCAL OF THE ROLE. DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A-
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL CALL
VOTE EYES FORTY SIX KNOWS TEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS. OUR
CONCURRENT. THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN. AB THREE ONE FOUR
FOUR COREY ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FOURTEEN BY SOME MEMBER BONTA
AN ACCOLADE THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT. MR BONTA YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB THREE
ONE FOUR IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AFTER AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN IN THE SENATE THAT
WERE TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK MISS BONTA SEEING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. CAR CLUB
THE ROLE. THESE ARE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSER ALL TITLEIST FORTY
NINE KNOWS NINE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM NINETEEN. AB SIX
FIFTY EIGHT CORPORATION. SOME
MIDDLE SIX FIFTY EIGHT BY SOME
REMEMBER ARAMBULA ANOTHER SNACK
LATER WATER. DOCTOR ARAMBULA
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB SIX
FIFTY EIGHT IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AB SIX FIFTY EIGHT
WILL ALLOW THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO ISSUE A FIVE YEAR
TEMPORARY URGENCY PERMIT THAT
WILL ALLOW GROUNDWATER'S
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES OR
LEGAL IT LOCAL AGENCIES TO
DIVERT WATER TO UNDERGROUND
STORAGE SENATE BENT AMENDMENTS
TO THIS BILL WERE CLARIFYING
AND TECHNICAL AND I ASK FOR
YOUR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU DOCTOR
REMINISCE SEEN NO DISCUSSION OF
A COUPLE OF IN THE RAW. NUMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WELL. CULTURAL TIE THAT I
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY AB
FIFTEEN SEVEN COVERAGE. SOME
PEOPLE FIFTEEN OH SEVEN BY SOME
MEMBERS SMITH ANOTHER SNACK
LATER CHARTER SCHOOLS. MISS
SMITH. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I CAN SEE THE PROMISED
LAND AB FIFTEEN OH SEVEN IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN BY STATING THAT SENATE
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE NEGOTIATED
AMENDMENTS THAT MAKE THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE. ADDITIONALLY
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
GRANDFATHERING FOR EXISTING
SCHOOLS AND ALLOW FLEXIBILITY
FOR RESOURCE CENTERS SO LONG AS
THEY ARE APPROVED BY THE LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AGAIN AB
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN RESTORES THE
RIGHT OF INDIVIDUAL DISTRICTS
TO HAVE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
SCHOOLS LOCATED WITHIN THEIR
GEOGRAPHIC BOUNDARIES AND
CLARIFIES THE JURISDICTIONAL
SOVEREIGNTY OF DULY ELECTED
SCHOOL BOARDS AND THEIR ROLE IN
PUBLIC OVERSIGHT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTER
CONCURRENT. THANK YOU MISS WITH
MISS WALDRON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN OH
SEVEN. CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
SOMETIMES THE ONLY WAY FOR
CHILDREN FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES TO ESCAPE OF FAILING
DISTRICT ONE SCHOOL THIS BILL
WILL LIMóN OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MANY STUDENTS BUT ENGLISH
LEARNERS DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS
AND CHILDREN AND GIFTED. AND
TALENTED PROGRAMS WILL BE
PARTICULARLY HARD HIT BY
RESTRICTIONS ON RESOURCE
CENTERS. IT'S UNTHINKABLE WE
WOULD ELIMINATE EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCE CENTERS AND PROVIDE
CONVENIENT ACCESS TO
PERSONALIZE INSTRUCTION AND
ADVANCED LEARNING FACILITIES
FOR STUDENTS AYE ORIGIN NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON. SEEING
NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. MISS
SMITH YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH.
MS SMITH YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH.
JUST ONE SECOND NINE OUT OF MY
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU MISS
SMITH THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. A WITHOUT.
THE ROLE. IS OUT OF THEM. ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE THE. THANK
YOU ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT ICE FORTY TWO KNOWS
FIFTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARCANE CURTIN. OKAY. WE ARE
GOING TO PASS. AND RETAIN. OF
FILE I'M TWENTY ONE CORRECTION
WE REFER FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE
TO COMMITTEE. WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM TWENTY TWO WHICH IS AB
EIGHTEEN TEN THE CORPORATION.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHTEEN TEN BY THE
COMMITTEE TRANSPORTATION AN
ACCOLADE TRANSPORTATION. IT'S
FRAZIER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB EIGHTEEN TEN IS THE
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE ON THE BUS BILL. IT
CONTAINS A NUMBER OF MINOR
CHANGES TO STATE WHAT LAW TO
IMPROVE TRANSPORTATION POLICY
IN CALIFORNIA. IT IS NON
CONTROVERSIAL AND HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. IN THE CURRENT. NAMES
FRAZIER SEEING NO DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL ALL
MEMBERS THE- DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ALL. TELL YOU THE I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS. OUR CONCURRED IN WE
REFER FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE WE
ARE AT FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR AB
ONE THIRTY BY MR LE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW
WHEN OTHERS AN ACCOLADE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION MR LOW
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SPEAKING MEMBERS THIS IT. BILLS
BACK ON CONCURRENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MISS LOW SENIOR DISCUSSION
ON THE ADAM CLERK WILL OPEN.
MEMBERS. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL TALBOT I
SIXTY FOUR KNOWS ONE. SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY FIVE AB SIX TWENTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TWENTY THREE
BY SOME MEMBER BERMAN ACRYLATE
TO ELECTIONS MR BERMAN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS THEY BE SIX TWENTY
THREE WOULD REQUIRE SECRETARY
OF STATE TO ESTABLISH A BALLOT
DESIGN COMMITTEE TO PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS FOR BALLOT DESIGN
AND FORMAT AND ADD DOUBLE
JOINTING LANGUAGE TO AVOID
CHAPTER PROBLEMS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. A WHISPER MINCING KASHER
DEBATE CLUB THE ROLE. IS OUT OF
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN. WE
HAVE A FOR FILE I'M TWENTY SIX
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN. WE
WILL TAKE A FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT AB EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR.
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR BY SOME%
REMEMBER IRWIN AN ACT RELATING
TO CONSUMER PRIVACY THIS ARE
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
OR IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THIS
BILL PASSED THE SENATE WITH
FORTY VOTES HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION THE BILL
AS A RESULT OF EXTENSIVE WORK
TO BRING THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
TOGETHER TO UNDERSTAND HOW TO
IMPLEMENT CCPA. AB EIGHT SEVEN
FOUR AVOIDS COSTLY CONFUSION
THAT WOULD PROLONG
IMPLEMENTATION PUSHING BACK
WHEN CALIFORNIANS COULD UTILIZE
THEIR NEW RIGHTS PROMISED TO
THEM BY CCPA. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE. THANK YOU
MISTER WOULD SEEM DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WELL THOSE
ARE ALL TIED UP I SIXTY NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARKIN CURTAIN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE
AB NINE TWENTY TWO THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
TWENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURKE AN ACCOLADE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH MISS BURKE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY TWO IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENT TO MOMENTS TAKEN
IN SENATE WERE TO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERN AND TO
CLEAR BY THE SPECIFIC INFORMED
CONSENT REQUIRED. FOR RESEARCH
PARTICIPANTS PROVIDING EGGS FOR
MEDICAL RESEARCH AS WELL AS IN
LA REPORT THAT WILL BE
DELIVERED TO THIS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON OR BEFORE MARCH
SEVENTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY TWO WAS
RECEIVED BY PARTISAN SUPPORTERS
BUCKLEY REQUEST. THAT WE
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS BURKE
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE. IS OUT OF
ALL MEMBERS OF A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I AS FIFTY ONE KNOWS. ZERO
SENATE MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY. AB
NINE THIRTY SIX CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THIRTY SIX
BY SOME REMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
ANOTHER SPECULATE OIL SPILLS
MYSTERY THIS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER UP FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO AGAIN PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE THREE SIX SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE  PRODUCT OF
EXTENSIVECOLLABORATION WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS A RESULT ALL
INDUSTRY OPPOSITION HAS BEEN
REMOVED. THIS BILL ENHANCES OIL
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT DOES SO BY
FIRST MAKING SURE THAT WE
DEFINE A NON FLOATING OIL IN
STATUTE SECOND IT WILL ENSURE
THAT SAFETY STANDARDS ARE
REGULARLY UPDATED TO REFLECT
THE BEST POSSIBLE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGY FOR CLEAN UP OF NON
FORTY OIL AND THIRD. CHOIR IN
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY MISSION.
SURE THAT THEY COLLECT AND
PUBLISH THE DATA. EARNS THE
MOVEMENT OF NONVOTING CRUDE BY
RAIL CAR AND VESSEL THIS BILL
WOULD ESSENTIALLY ENSURE THAT
OUR STATE WILL BE. WE'LL BE
PREPARED TO DEAL WITH BILLS OF
THESE NONPOINT OILS OILS MOST
LIKELY TO CAUSE LASTING DAMAGE
TO OUR MARINE ENVIRONMENT
WATERWAYS AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THREE SIX IS
ABOUT SAFETY AND PREPAREDNESS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS CONCURRENT BOAT
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK
YOU IS RIVAS DEAN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBER
SERVICE OUR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS A DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY FIVE KNOWS FIVE. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. I
WISH I AM PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL. ON. FIVE ARMY ON AB ONE
FIFTEEN. THE BUDGET ITEM THE
CLERK WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE.
CLARK WELL ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WILL CLOSE
ROLE TELL YOU ABOUT. ICE FIFTY
FOUR. NO SIX SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT IN IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO ENGROSSING. AND
IN ROLLING
. MISTER CALDERON
HERE RECOGNIZE. THANK. MISTER
SPEAKER MY BAD BY AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE AHEAD NINETY TWO SB FIVE
TWENTY FOUR STERN TO THE IMAC
TO FILE. THE CLERK WILL KNOW. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER TO SPEAK
ON A GERMAN MEMBER TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
IS GRANTED. MEMBERS WE ARE BACK
ON THE CONCURRENCE FILE. IN
FILE OR THIS IS FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE AB TEN EIGHTY THREE
COVERAGE. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
EIGHTY THREE BY SIMPLY MEMBER
BURKE AN ACCOLADE TO ENERGY. MS
BURKE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I MEMBERS AB TEN OF EIGHTY
THREE AUTHORIZES MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO REQUEST AN
ANALYSIS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL ON SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY OR C. C. S. T. ON
PROPOSED MEASURES DEALING WITH
ENERGY PROCUREMENT AND
INFRASTRUCTURE MANDATE SENATE
AMENDMENTS REQUIRE THAT THE
ANNOUNCES MUST INCLUDE REVIEW
OF COSTS. AND BENEFITS ON
PUBLIC HEALTH IN CLIMB
INSTABILITY AND THAT C. C. S.
T. WILL ONLY CONDUCTING NOW
SAYS IT WOULD HAVE SUFFICIENT
FUNDS TO DO SO I. REQUEST I.
BUT. THERE WAS BURKE SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLARK
LIBERAL MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE
HELLO. I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO.
SEVEN MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED AND
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO IS AB
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN THE CLERK READ
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
BY SOME MEMBER BLOCK A RUBIO
AND ACTUALLY THE LAND USE THIS
RUBIO THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE TO PRESENT AB ONE ONE
ONE EIGHT THE H. FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ACT WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ALIGN THE BILL THE GOVERNOR'S
RECENT EXECUTIVE ORDER ON THE
MASTER PLAN ON AGING. THIS BILL
WOULD DIRECT THE SECRETARY
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY TO JOIN A. R.
P.'S NETWORK OF AGE FROM THE
STATES. AND COMMUNITIES ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
POSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST RIGHT OUT. THANK YOU MS
RUBIO SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CAR CLUB THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS A DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS LETTERS OUT OF IT
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL TIES
BUT I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SAN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILING THIRTY THREE IS AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE. COVERAGE
SOME GIRL ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE BY
SOME MEMBER REALLY MONNING
ACTUALLY CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS. IS LAMAR THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE IS BACK
ON CONCURRENT AND SEEKS TO
ENSURE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCURACY IN THE REPORTING OF
NON CASH PHARMACEUTICAL
DONATIONS BY CHARITY SUBJECT TO
REGULATION BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. SENATE AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL DELAY IMPLEMENTATION BY
WHEN YOU'RE AND ALLOW THE AG'S
OFFICE TO DO REAL MAKING ON THE
SUBJECT TO PROVIDE FURTHER
GUIDANCE TO CHARITIES IT WAS
ALSO NEAR TO ONLY APPLY TO
SPECIFIC DONATIONS THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I. BUT.
THANK REDLANDS CA NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLARK LIBERAL. DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIGN OF
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FOLLOWING THIRTY FOUR AB
TWELVE NINETEEN. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE NINETEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER
IMMACULATELY TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. MR JOHNSON THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AMENDMENTS
IN THE SENATE REFLECT
NEGOTIATIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
ANY ADMINISTRATION TO EASE
IMPLEMENTATION THESE AMENDMENT
FOR MOVES ALL OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. IN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLERK LIBERAL.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF THE CLERK WILL.
CULTURAL TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN
. MEMBERS THIS
IS FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO CORKERY
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY TWENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACT LIKE SCHOOL
HEALTH. MR BERMAN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE BILL
WOULD ESTABLISH A SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH UNIT WITHIN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
INCORPORATE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AS WELL AS ADD CO
AUTHORS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
ALL MEMBERS A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRED
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. KIRK WELL CLOSER ALL
TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN. FILE ITEM THIRTY
SIX IS AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
CORKERY SO MICHAEL THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX BY SOME WE WERE
WITHIN ANOTHER SNACK LATER POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION A MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR. MR MEDINA
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
IS BACK FOR CONSERVE CURRENTS
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
IN NATURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MEDINA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CAR CLUB
RURAL MEMBERS. DESIRE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
WELL CLOSER ROLE KELLY THE VOTE
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS PARKING HEARD IN
. WE
WILL PASS RETAIN A VIOLENT
THIRTY SEVEN FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT AB FOURTEEN THIRTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN BY SOME
REMEMBER GLORIA AND ACTUALLY
THE TRANSPORTATION. GLORIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT AT
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN WHICH IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
SENATE AND THEN IT'S- NEAR THE
BILL TO PLASTER SAN DIEGO AND
SO MONO COUNTY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER GLORIA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS MOODY'S
ARE THOSE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE AYE AYES FORTY FOUR NEWS
SIXTEEN THIS SENTIMENT ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY SOME
REMEMBER GRAYSON AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE HOUSING GRAYSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTY THREE IS BACK ON
CURRENTS. SENT MEN MINUTES
REQUIRES LOCAL AGENCIES TO POST
ON THEIR WEBSITES THE TYPE AND
AMOUNT OF EACH BE IMPOSED ON A
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECT THE
CURRENT FIVE PREVIOUS ANNUAL
FEE REPORTS AND ANY APPLICABLE
NEXUS OR COST OF SERVICE
STUDIES THIS IMPORTANT CHANGE
LET MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY
UNCERTAINTY TO THE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT APPLICATION PROCESS
AND BY BRINGING TRANSPARENCY.
TO THE WAY CITIES LEVY AND
JUSTIFY THEIR DEVELOPER FEES WE
WILL BE POSITION TO IMPLEMENT
SMART EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS. TO
OUR HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I. THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO THE- ALL
MEMBERS NOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM FORTY AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX BY SOME REMEMBER TING
ANOTHER SNACK LATER SURPLUS
LAND RESEARCHING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB FORTY SIX BOTTLE
CONCURRENCE. HE TOOK A MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE TO REMOVE
OPPOSITION FROM SPECIAL
DISTRICT HEALTH DISTRICTS WATER
AGENCIES SANITATION AGENCIES
AND MUNICIPAL UTILITY AGENCIES
AMONG OTHERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER TING.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG. YOU
DESERVE A ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THERE TO
VOTE. WORK WILL LOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY
NINE KNOWS TWELVE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM FORTY ONE EIGHTY
FIFTEEN THIRTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME PEOPLE FIFTY THIRTEEN
BY SOME RIVER HOLDEN AN
ACCOLADE ENERGY. HOLDEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN
THIRTEEN IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
WITH ONE EXCEPTION AB FIFTEEN
THIRTEEN IS STRAIGHTFORWARD
CODE CLEANUP BILL IT MAKES
SEVERAL CLARIFYING AND
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO VARIOUS
SECTIONS OF THE CODE FIXES
DATES AND CORRECT GRAMMAR. THIS
MEASURE WAS AS ONE SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENT PERTAINING TO THE
WALL FAR FUND THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN A. B. TEN FIFTY
FOUR UPON THE TERMINATION OF
THE FUN ANY REMAINING REVENUES
ARE TRANSFERRED GENERAL FUND
WITH THE INTENT THAT THEY STILL
BE USED FOR WILDFIRE MEDICATION
THIS MEASURE HAS NO OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
INCIDENT AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
MISTER HOLDEN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL LOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE I CITY SIX NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN PASS AND RETAIN A VIOLATED
FORTY TWO FILE ITEM FORTY THREE
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME REAL. MISS REST
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY SIX IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL IS A
LATINO CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL
WHICH ENSURES THAT INFORMATION
ABOUT THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS
BE AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS AND
THE PARENTS OR GUARDIANS AT
SCHOOLS. THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENSUS SIX TO COUNT EVERYONE SO
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE ENSURE
THAT EVERY PERSON LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA IS ACCURATELY
COUNTED FOR AND WE KNOW THAT
SCHOOLS ARE ONE OF THE MOST
TRUSTED INSTITUTIONS WITH THE
CENSUS FAST APPROACHING THIS
BILL WAS AMENDED TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS READ SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE
KNOWS YOUR SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE. AND I SIXTY
ONE KNOWS HERE ON THE URGENCY.
FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR A. B.
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME BILLS SIXTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER
CAREER ON OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
RESOURCES CONSERVATION THIS
CAREER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT AT THE
BACK. FOR CONCURRENT THE
AMENDMENTS PROHIBIT THE PROGRAM
FOR FROM REPLACING OR
RESTRICTING EXISTING FUTURE
PROGRAMS AND TRAINING OFFERED
TO FORMALLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND ADDRESS COST
CONCERNS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I HAVE A- THANK YOU MISS
CARILLO SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL LOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
FORTY FIVE AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE A
STATE PARKS. MR LEVINE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKERS AND MEMBERS MAY
THIS BE THE LAST TIME THAT I
PRESENT THIS BILL THAT WILL
FINALLY BANNED SMOKING ON. ON
OUR STATE BEACHES AND IN OUR
STATE PARKS PROTECTING OUR
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT AND
WILDLIFE FROM THE POISONS AND
TOXINS IN OUR CIGARETTES THAT
ARE LEFT BEHIND THAT POLLUTE
OUR BEACHES IN WATER WAYS THAT
PROTECT US IN OUR STATE PARKS
AS WELL MEMBERS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESERTED THE- HOME MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THOUGHDIES FORTY FIVE
NEWS FIFTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN BY LEN FORTY
SIX AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM ACTIVATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT MR BLOOM YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
THREE IS HERE ON CONCURRENCE.
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS CHAPTER RING
OUT ISSUE AND CLARIFYING THE
HOUSING ON ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
THAT IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS ELIGIBILITY FOR
THE WELFARE EXEMPTION IS NOT A
LEGAL BASIS ON WHICH TO DIE
DENIED THE PROJECT I'LL BET
YOU'RE GLAD TO FIND THAT OUT.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS ERICA. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS ONCE IN AN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FORTY
SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN NINETY THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY NINETY BY SOME MEMBER
WEEKS ANOTHER SNACK RELATED
BUSINESS MISS WICKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
SEVENTEEN NINETY IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THIS. IS THE FIRST
IN THE NATION BILL ASSURING
BASIC FAIRNESS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THIRD PARTY
SELLERS WHO SELL ON MARKET
PLACES LIKE AMAZON SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDED SOME MORE
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY
MEASURES THIS BILL HAS A BROAD
LIST OF SUPPORTERS INCLUDING
WORKERS WORKING PARTNERSHIPS
USA THE GROCERS THE RETAILERS
THE UFCW AND OTHERS AFTER A
SERIES OF NEGOTIATIONS WITH
AMAZON. CAL CAL CHEAPER MS ON
CAL CHAMBER TECH NET AND OTHERS
HAVE REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION
OR NON NEUTRAL ON THE BILL THE
BILL INJURIES BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT BOTH HOUSES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WICKS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK.
WILL OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE HE DESIRED TO VOTE.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY NOTE I SIX YOU KNOW ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB ONE
SEVENTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME EVERYONE SEVENTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER CHAO
ANOTHER SNACK LATER MOBILE
HOMES CHAO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB ONE
SEVENTY THREE WOULD EXTEND THE
SUNSET ON ATTACK THE BASEMENT
PROGRAM CALLED. THIS IS YOUR
MOBILE HOME CALIFORNIA FOR ONE
YEAR THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
REMOVE ALL OPPOSITION AND
ADDRESS TECHNICAL ISSUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAO SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESERTED THE. ON MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THOUGH IT AYE SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE AB TWO FORTY TO THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE ANOTHER SNACK
LATER IMPLICIT BIAS COM LONGER
THAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU DID A AFTERNOON MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWO FOUR TWO
IS BACK FROM SENATE CONCURRENCE
THE CONCURRENCE IN EXTENDERS
FOR THE STATEBAR APPROVAL OF
M. C. ELLIE PROVIDERS WHO ARE
AUTHORIZED. TO OFFER THIS
TRAINING I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THEY GIVE US
KAMLAGER-DOVE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. WORK WELL CLOSE
THE ROLAND TALLY VOTE ICE FIFTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
FIFTY AB FOR ELEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
ELEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER MARK
STONE ACKERLEY TO REDEVELOPMENT
MR STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ASK
FOR CONCURRENCE IN THE SENATE'S
CHAPTER IN AMENDMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER STONE CA. ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE.
ALL MEMBERS NOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. I THOUGHT FILE
ITEM FIFTY ONE AB FOR TWENTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
PEOPLE FOR TWENTY THREE BY SOME
REMEMBER GLORIA AN ACCOLADE TO
THE SENATE SAN DIEGO COUNTY AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT MR
GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY SPEAKER A. B. FOR
TWENTY THREE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENT SENATE MINUTES MAKE
MODIFICATIONS THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT BOARD STRUCTURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE
EYES FORTY NINE NEWS THIRTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN
. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE OH ONE ON
THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE
SBONE THIRTY SIX THE CLERK%
WILL READ. SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY SIX BY CENTER WIENER
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE SYNCING.
SIR KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS. TODAY I RISE AS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF SENATE
BILL ONE THIRTY SIX. AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW BY NOW SB ONE THIRTY
SIX REPEALS THE ONE YEAR PRIOR
FELONY SENTENCING ENHANCEMENT
FOR MANY BUT LOW LEVEL FELONY
OFFENSES IT EXCLUDES WHEN
YOU'RE HAS IS BEING SERVED AT
COUNTY JAILS. ARE THE BILL ONLY
REPEALS WHEN YOUR ENHANCEMENT.
FOR LOW LEVEL OFFENSES IS NOT
APPLIED AS TIME SERVED IN
COUNTY JAILS. AS A FORMER
PUBLIC DEFENDER W. DEFENDER
LEVIN YEARS. I HAVE FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE REGARDING THIS
ENHANCEMENT. WHAT I'VE
EXPERIENCE IS NOT DISSIMILAR TO
WHAT RESEARCH AND STATISTICS
HAVE SHOWN. THAT THIS
ENHANCEMENT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY USED AGAINST
PERSONS OF COLOR AND THOSE WERE
LOW INCOME. IN FACT THIS
ENHANCEMENT IS BETTER DESCRIBED
AS TOP ON TIME SERVED RATHER
THAN TOUGH ON CRIME WHICH
EXACERBATES EXISTING RACIAL AND
SOCIO ECONOMIC DISPARITIES THAT
PERSIST WITHIN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. IT IS A RELIC
OF OUR STATE STARK HISTORY OF
PURSUING MASS INCARCERATION AS
A MEANS OF COMBATING CRIME. IS
UNNECESSARY AND INEFFECTIVE A
ABILITY OF CHEAP OF GB
REHABILITATION BUT IT DOES TO
GIVE US COMFORT. IN COMBATING
CRIME AND CONTRARY TO WHAT IS
BEING ARE YOU BY THE OPPOSITION
THIS BILL DOES NOT ELIMINATE
TOOLS PROSECUTORS MAY USE SB
ONE THIRTY SIX WILL NOT
PRECLUDE ENHANCEMENTS FOR
PEOPLE CONVICTED OF FELONY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ARMED
ROBBERY. OF A RAPE OF A CHILD
AS OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL WOULD
LIKE YOU TO BELIEVE THESE
REMAIN APPLICABLE OTHER AS
MISALIGNED OF THOSE EXTREMELY
SERIOUS CRIMES. AND THIS
PARTICULAR BILL ALSO EXCLUDES.
TONY SEXUAL CRIMES AS WELL. SO
FOR EXAMPLE CALIFORNIA HAS
SENDS ENHANCES SPECIFIC TO
REPEAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD
ABUSE RAPE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AND MANY MANY OTHER SERIOUS
OFFENSES MOREOVER. IN ADDITION
TO THOSE DISPERSE CLIENTS
SPECIFIC ENHANCEMENTS
CALIFORNIA HAS A CATCH ALL
THREE YEAR SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT
FOR REPEAT VIOLENT FELONY
OFFENDERS ON A FIVE YEAR
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT REPEAT
SERIAL TONY EVENT A SERIOUS
FELONY OFFENDERS. AND I THE
THREE YEAR AND HAS BEEN OR THE
FIVE YEAR AND HAS A CAN BE
COMBINED WITH THE ONE YEAR AND
HAS WITH THAT AS TWO ONE THREE
SIX. SIX TO REPEAL. ON TOP OF
THAT PROSECUTORS STILL HAVE
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DIFFERENT SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS TO CHOOSE FROM AND
SENTENCED A REPEAT OFFENDER.
REPEALING THIS INEFFECTIVE AND
COMMONLY USED ONE YEAR SENTENCE
AND HANDSOME WITH SAVE OUR
STATE APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR
IMPOSE. WHILE ENSURING THAT
EACH PERSON IS TREATED ACT
REALLY UNDER THE LAW WITHOUT
SACRIFICING JUSTICE FOR VICTIMS
OR PUBLIC SAFETY. GIVEN THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED SERVING THIS ONE
YOUR ENHANCEMENT TAXPAYERS. ARE
PUTTING A BILL ACCESS ONE
BILLION. SB ONE THIRTY SIX ENDS
THIS MASS INCARCERATION
APPROACH FOR LOW LEVEL
OFFENDERS THAT HAS PROVEN TO BE
INEFFECTIVE AND
DISPROPORTIONATE HURTS PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND LOW INCOME.
COMMUNITIES IT IS A
SLEDGEHAMMER APPROACH A
SENTENCING THAT. AS OPPOSED TO
A SCALPEL APPROACH AND ACTUALLY
HAS A PUNISHMENT FIT THE CRIME
AND IT IS AN ENHANCEMENT THAT
IS USED. BROADLY AND CLEARLY
USED AGAINST THOSE THAT ARE
ALREADY ARE. VICTIMIZED BY A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT IS
SHOWN IMPLICIT BIAS BUT OVER
THE DECADES SO COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT REMOVING.
THIS PARTICULAR ENHANCEMENT
DOES NOT IN ANY WAY TAKE AWAY
TOOLS NECESSARY TO ENSURE THE
PUNISHMENT FITS THE CRIME FOR
ANY GIVEN CONVICTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA MISTER.
I THANK. YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB ONE THIRTY SIX THIS BILL
CONTINUES A TREND OF REMOVING
PROTECTIONS FOR LAW ABIDING
CALIFORNIANS WHILE ALLOWING
THOSE ALREADY CONVICTED OF A
FELONY TO ESCAPE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR ACTIONS
SB ONE THIRTY SIX WILL ALLOW
THOSE CONVICTED WITH A HISTORY
OF REPEATED FELONIES TO BE
TREATED LIKE FIRST TIME
OFFENDERS THIS BILL ENDS ONE
YEAR SENTENCING ENHANCEMENTS
FOR CONVICTED CRIMINALS WHO CO.
COMMITTED MULTIPLE FELONIES.
YES A FENCE WAS CONSIDERED NON
VIOLENT THIS IS. AND HAS BEEN
IS AUTOMATICALLY REMOVED
WITHOUT REGARD TO THE SEVERITY
OF MULTIPLE FELONIES EXAMPLES
OF VIOLENT CRIMES WHERE THE ONE
YEAR HAS NO WE REMOVED BY SB
ONE THREE SIX INCLUDE LEWD ACTS
ON A CHILD UNDER FOURTEEN WITH
A PRIOR CONVICTION FOR CHILD
ENDANGERMENT IN FORCIBLE RAPE
WITH PYRE. FICTION FOR ELDER
ABUSE. THE LOSERS OF THIS BILL
ARE THE- THOSE AFFECTED BY
VIOLENT CRIME WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO REMOVE PROTECTIONS
FOR THE PUBLIC AN EXPECTED
JUSTICE TO BE SERVED I URGE IN
OF A- THANK YOU MISTER FONG MR
CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MISTER
CAMPAIGN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FROM A DENSE FRICKER I WANT TO
THANK THE SCENT OF HER PHONE
SAN FRANCISCO FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FOR AND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN JOSE. FULL JOCKEY THIS ON
OUR FLOOR WHILE IT IS A GREAT
IT IS REALLY GREAT THAT WE WORK
TO REFORM OR- A JEW JUSTICE
SYSTEM I THINK MORE COMPETITION
NEED TO HAPPEN AROUND WHAT. WE
SHOULD DO WITH THE MONEY WE
SAVED FROM THESE REFORMS. I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
INVEST IN SUPPORTING
INDIVIDUALS ALL OF PRISON TO
HELP THEM TO GET BACK TO THEIR
FEET AND NOT. RE OFFEND I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY AND I WOULD LIKE TO WORK
WITH ANYONE MY COLLEAGUES. WHO
ARE INTERESTED IN MAKING OR THE
SAVING FROM THE JUST A RIFF ON
BE SPENT ON THOSE. LOOKING TO
RESTART THEIR LIVES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MR GRAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ROCK MUSICIAN.
AND I WANT TO LOOK AT THIS FROM
A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE THAN WHAT I'VE JUST
HEARD ON THIS FOR WHICH IN FACT.
DOES THIS PROVIDE SOME
FLEXIBILITY. WITHIN THE
SENTENCING. WORLD I THINK IT
DOES. WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE- TRIAL OF DEFENSIVE GOT
THREE SIX NINE YEAR. SENTENCE
POSSIBILITIES YOU CAN ADD
ENHANCEMENT. ON THE LOW TERM
VERSUS THE MID TERM YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE PROSECUTORS. SIMPLY
MORE RETICENT. TO FIND THOSE
DEALS AND SO. I THINK WHEN IT
COMES TO DISCRETION FLEXIBILITY
THAT'S BEEN THE DIRECTION OF
THIS FOR THIS BODY. I THINK THE
INTENT THIS AUTHOR MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE BUT I THINK IN
PRACTICE. WE'RE MOVING IN THE
EXACT OPPOSITE DIRECTION. THAT
WE'VE ALL WORK SO HARD INCOME
JUST FOR SO. RESPECTFULLY AGAIN
ALL CONTENT IS I THINK YOU'RE
GOOD. BUT I THINK WE NEED TO
CONSIDER THE IMPLICATIONS AND
THE PRACTICAL FACT. AND VOTE NO
TODAY ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER GRAHAM MISTER MURATSUCHI
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL I'M READING A
LETTER FROM THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE THAT CONTRARY TO WHAT
WAS PRESENTED ON THIS BILL THIS
IS NOT IS NOT LIMITED TO. NON
SERIOUS NON VIOLENT CRIMES
ACCORDING TO THE LA DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SB ONE THREE SIX WILL
ELIMINATE THE ONE HERE IN HAND
SPENT FOR REPEAT FELONS FOR
PRIOR SUCH AS FELONY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE OR FELONY CHILD ABUSE.
COLLEAGUES THESE ARE NOT NON
SERIOUS NON VIOLENT CRIMES. AND
YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW
OUR. EFFORTS FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM BUT WE CAN'T
TAKE AWAY THE TOOLS FROM
PROSECUTORS TO EXERCISE OF
DISCRETION TO FILE THESE ONE
YEAR ENHANCEMENTS YOU KNOW FOR
CAREER CRIMINALS THESE ARE THE
DANGEROUS CRIMINALS THAT WE
SHOULD BE LOCKING UP AND KEEP
AN EYE OUT OF THAT THE PUBLIC
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY. YOU KNOW
LET'S NOT LOSE OUR CREDIBILITY
DEMOCRATS YOU KNOW BY PUSHING
FOR ALL THESE PROMOTE JUSTICE
REFORM BILLS WHERE YOU KNOW IT
THESE ARE BILLS AGAIN THEY'RE
GOOD THEY'RE GOING AFTER. THE
ABOVE FOR PRIOR IS LIKE FELONY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE FELONY CHILD
ABUSE. I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI MISS COME LONGER W.
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE THREE SIX AS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR I'VE HEARD SOME OF THE
DEBATE AND JUST LET ME PROVIDE
SOME CONTEXT FOR MY COLLEAGUES
WHO MAY NOT BE FULLY AWARE OF
THE SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS WITH
THIS BILL. CALIFORNIA WENT ON
AN INCARCERATED INCARCERATION
BANDS IN THE EIGHTIES AND THE
NINETIES AND WE TRULY HAVE YET
TO RECOVER. FROM NINETEEN
EIGHTY TO TWO THOUSAND BOTH THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
WIN ON A SPREE OF SENTENCING
INFLATION. THAT RESULTED IN A
PRISON POPULATION GREATER THAN
4100% WE FUNDED LONGER
SENTENCES INSTEAD OF EDUCATION
MENTAL ILLNESS JOB TRAINING OR
HOUSING. AND AS A RESULT. WE
FOUND OURSELVES IN A CIRCUIT
OVERLOAD AND SO IN TWENTY
ELEVEN. THE SUPREME COURT RULED
THAT WE WERE INCOMPETENT TO RUN
OUR OWN PRISONS AND WERE PUT IN
STATE FEDERAL RECEIVERSHIP. IF
WE WERE A NATION. ON TO OUR
SOUTH OUR INCARCERATION RATES
WOULD BE COMPARABLE TO RUSSIA
THAT IS TWO TIMES THE RATE IN
MEXICO VENEZUELA OR IRAQ AND
THREE TIMES THE RATE OF CHINA
EGYPT OR CANADA. AND FIVE TIMES
THE RATE OF ANY NORTHERN
EUROPEAN COUNTRY. BUT TALK TO
ME. ABOUT OUR RECIDIVISM RATE
WE ARE AMONG THE HIGHEST AT
OVER 65% NOW I COULD TALK ABOUT
THE RACIAL UNDERCURRENT OR OVER
CURRENT OF OUR INCARCERATIONS
SENTENCE SYSTEM BUT I'M NOT
GOING TO INSTEAD I'M GONNA TALK
ABOUT MONEY. I'M GONNA TALK
ABOUT TAX MONEY I'M GONNA TALK
ABOUT OUR MONEY. YOU SHOULD
ACTUALLY SEE THIS BILL. AS A
TAX CUTS NOT FOR THE RICH NOT
FOR CERTAIN COMPANIES OR
CORPORATIONS BUT FOR EVERYONE.
MONEY CONTROLS THIS DEBATE
MONEY IN FEAR WHICH I WILL TALK
ABOUT A LITTLE LATER SO EVERY
TIME EVERY TIME A JUDGE TAX ON
A SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS THAT IS
BROADER THAT IS EXTRA MONEY
EXTRA TIME. FOR THIS SYSTEM.
IT'S TAX MONEY THAT COULD BE
GOING BACK INTO OUR COMMUNITIES
DOLLARS THAT WE ARE FIGHTING SO
DESPERATELY FOR ON THIS FLOOR
WE COULD BE SPENDING THAT MONEY
FOR BRIDGES FOR HOUSING FOR
SCHOOLS FOR ROADS. FOR WILD
FIRE MANAGEMENT. TODAY IT COSTS
EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR TO HOUSE AN INMATE IN OVER
THREE QUARTERS OF THAT MONEY
GOES TO HEALTH CARE AND
SECURITY. SINCE TWENTY TEN.
THAT COST HAS GONE UP BY 58% BY
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS. SO
THE OPPOSITIONLETTERS THAT
WE'VE ALL BEEN GETTING SCARING
US TO DEATH WHAT THEY DON'T
TALK ABOUT IS THE MONEY THE
MONEY THAT THESE GROUPS DON'T
WANT TO LOSE. THAT WE KNOW. BY
NOT PASSING THIS BILL GOES BACK
INTO A FAILING SYSTEM WITH A
HIGH RECIDIVISM RATE OR A LOW
RETURN ON INVESTMENT. OF OUR
MONEY. CONSTITUENTS YOU'RE
SCARED THAT CONSTITUENTS WILL
SAY WELL WHY DID YOU VOTE FOR
THIS BILL WHY DID YOU VOTE YES
ON THIS BILL WHY DON'T YOU TELL
THEM I'M VOTING FOR THIS BILL
BECAUSE I WANT TO GIVE YOU YOUR
MONEY BACK YOUR TAX DOLLARS
THAT ARE GOING INTO A RIGGED
SYSTEM NOT DESIGNED TO HELP
FOLKS NOT RECIDIVISTS. SO I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOU BACK THAT
MONEY TO WE FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CREATE A SYSTEM THAT WORKS.
THAT IS AN ALLOWS ALSO FOR
REHABILITATION IN A LOWER
RECIDIVISM RATE BECAUSE THIS
RIGHT HERE IS NOT WORKING.
FIFTEEN YEARS ON A SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT COST. US ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS DON'T YOU
THINK THAT MONEY COULD BE
SPENT. BETTER. AN SP ONE THREE
SIX. I'M SORRY TO HAVE TO
CONTRADICT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN SET IT KEEPS
JUDICIAL DISCRETION. DEFENDERS
GO BACK TO PRISON THEREARE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PLUS OTHER
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT FOR YOUR
PLEASURE STILL ON THE BOOKS.
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ABUSERS
CHILD ABUSERS WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE LONGER SENTENCES. WHAT
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT BUT I WILL
SAY. IS THAT YOU KNOW WE DON'T
PUNISH EQUALLY. BECAUSE WE
DON'T MONITOR SECONDS MISS COME
OVER AND WE DON'T PROSECUTE
EQUALLY. AND UNTIL WE FIX THAT.
WE NEED TO DO RIGHT. BY
REPEALING THE SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT. IF YOU DO NOT VOTE
ON THIS BILL. THEN YOU ARE NOT
WORKING TO FIX A SYSTEM THAT IS
BROKEN AND THAT IS RATE AND
THAT IS COSTING YOU AND YOUR
CONSTITUENTS MONEY THAT THEY
DESERVE TO SEE SPENT BETTER I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB ONE
THREE SIX THANK YOU IS
COMMENTED OUT OF MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK MISSION MADAM SPEAKER UP.
MEMBERS I THINK I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO FOOT TO
REALLY CLARIFY WHAT THIS BILL
REALLY DOES IN THE PROBLEMS
THAT ARE INHERENT IN AND OUT
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO GET INTO A
LOT OF DISCUSSIONS HERE WITH
RESPECT TO WHO SAID WHAT AND
WHAT DOES IT REALLY DO. THESE
ARE THE FAX. THEY ARE THE FACTS
THAT HAVE BEEN DEMONSTRATED BY
AND ALICE'S. A BY PEOPLE IN IN
POSITIONS TO NOW. DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN CALIFORNIA. IS NO
LONGER EITHER A VIOLENT FELONY.
OR A SERIOUS FELONY. THE AXE UP
AND THIS IS FACTUAL IN THE IN
THE ANALYSIS IF YOU DON'T WANT
TO ADMIT IT THAT'S FINE AND
DANDY. BUT THESE ARE THE FACTS.
THE ACTS OF SERIAL DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ARE NOT EXEMPT FROM SB
ONE THREE SIX. SB ONE THREE SIX
WILL MAKE THE CURRENT ONE YOUR
SENTENCING ENHANCEMENT FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE NON EXISTENT.
IT WILL REPEAL ALL ONE YEAR
ENHANCEMENTS FOR CONVICTIONS ON
MANY CRIMES AGAINST THE FAMILY
ESPECIALLY AGAINST WOMEN. MAY
GIVE YOU EXAMPLE IF A MAN IS
CONVICTED OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND HAS PRIOR REPEAT
CONVICTIONS FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE OR
STOCKING SB ONE THREE SIX WOULD
TAKE THE DISCRETION AWAY FROM
THE JUDGES TO ADD THAT ONE
YEAR. ADDITIONAL ENHANCEMENTS.
SB ONE THREE SIX WILL PROTECT
REPEAT OFFENDERS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WHILE PUSHING THE
VICTIM ASIDE. MEMBERS THIS BODY
IS INCREASINGLY SENDING A
SIGNAL TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT IT CARES MORE
FOR REPEAT CRIMINALS THEN THEY
DO FOR REPEAT VICTIM THIS IS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE I STRONGLY URGE
YOUR NO VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
PATTERSON MISTER JONES SAWYER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER. ONE A YEAR
ENHANCEMENTS JUST DON'T WORK
AND WE KNOW THAT BY THE BLOATED
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT WE
HAVE ESPECIALLY. IN OUR PRISONS.
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING NOW IS WHAT
STARTED THIS WHOLE CYCLE A ONE
YEAR ENHANCEMENTS MANDATORY
MINIMUMS JUST THINK OF FEAR.
THIS FEAR. THAT THEY HAVE UP
SPEAKING ABOUT ALL THE CRIMES
IN CRIMINALS THEY'RE OUT THERE
TO SCARE YOU INTO KEEPING MORE
A MORE PEOPLE INCARCERATED
WHILE NOT EVEN THINKING ABOUT.
JUDGES DISCRETION THAT THEY CAN
LOOK INTO A PERSONS I KNOW
THEIR RECORD AND WHETHER OR NOT
THEY SHOULD BE RELEASED. THE
FEAR THAT IF YOU DON'T GIVE DE
ACE THE DISCRETION. TO ADMIT TO
DO HARSH COURT SENTENCES ON
THESE INDIVIDUALS THEN YOU'RE
TAKING AWAY. THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT
TO PUNISH PEOPLE TO THE MAX.
AND AS WE VOTED ON TODAY WE
LEARNED TODAY IF YOU VOTED FOR
ONE OF THE BILLS WERE DA'S HAD
THE DISCRETION TO TRY TO TAKE
AWAY YOUR ABILITY ON THIS
FLOOR. TO CHANGE LAW WHICH IS
OUR RESPONSIBILITY. AND YOU
VOTED TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
LATER ON YOU CHANGE THE RULES
THE SOMEONE COULDN'T GIVE AWAY
THEIR PLEA BARGAIN. ABILITY
THAT THEY WOULD PLEA BARGAINED
OR THE RIGHTS OF WEIGHT LATER
ON. AND SO FOR ME ONE YEAR IT
ENHANCEMENTS WHAT TOOLS TO USE
TO KEEP PEOPLE IN JAIL LONGER
WE ALSO TALKED ABOUT GETTING
RID OF. THE PRIVATE PRISONS WHY
ARE WE DOING THAT BECAUSE YOU
TALK ABOUT COST THE COST OF
THIS. FEAR BASED SYSTEM IT JUST
GOTTEN TOO MUCH. COME ON DJJ
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YOUTH. TO REHABILITATE THEM
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
TO KEEP SOMEONE IN JAIL. AND WE
STILL ARE INCREASING THE
NUMBERS WE'VE INCREASING
NUMBERS EVERY YEAR EVERY DECADE
SO IT'S NOT WORKING WE GOTTA
STOP TRYING TO DO THE SAME
THING OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND EXPECTING DIFFERENT
RESULTS. WE CANNOT LET FEAR
DRIVE US WE CANNOT LET FEAR
DRIVERS TO A POINT WHERE WE GO
BACK. TO THE OLD TESTAMENT WAY
OF AN EYE FOR AN EYE. WE'RE
GONNA START CUTTING PEOPLE'S
HARMS OFF. WHAT ARE WE TRYING
TO SHOW RIGHT NOW WE GOT A SHOW
NOT ONLY COMPASSION WE GOT TO
START USING OUR HEADS TO DO
THIS IN A DIFFERENT WAY SO NOT
ONLY DO WE REDUCE THE LEVEL OF
PEOPLE THERE INCARCERATED. BUT
IF WE DO HAVE TO KEEP SOMEONE
INCARCERATED WE HAVE JUDGES. WE
HAVE PAROLE BOARDS WE HAVE
OTHERS THAT WILL MAKE THAT
DECISION TO KEEP THAT PERSON
SAFE. LEE IN CAR SURVEYED AND
SAFE FROM THE FROM THE
RESIDENTS THAT YOU ALL TALK
ABOUT YOU WANT TO PROTECT.
LET'S WORK TO CHANGE THE SYSTEM
SO WORKS FOR EVERYONE. NOT ONLY
THE VICTIMS NOT ONLY TO PRIVATE
CITIZENS BUT MOST IMPORTANT. WE
CHANGE THE SYSTEM SO THAT IT IS
FAIR. IS FAIR FOR EVERYONE AND
IT WAS JUST STOP THIS INCESSANT
NEED. TO SEEK REVENGE ON
INDIVIDUALS AND THAT WE START
SHOWING LIKE A NEW TESTAMENT
WAY OF UNDERSTANDING THAT
PEOPLE CAN CHANGE. PEOPLE CAN
GROW AND PEOPLE CAN IMPROVE SO
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER JONES
SAWYER MISTER GIVE SEND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE THIRTY SIX I
WANT TO COMMAND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN JOSE FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL OF FOUR TO FLOOR JOCKEY
FOR SENATOR ARE WIENER AND ALSO
WANT TO APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUES WHO OF. LOS ANGELES
I THINK WELFARE IS CERTAINLY I
WAS SPEAKING A LARGE VOICE I'M
HAVE SOME NOTES HERE BUT I'M
NOT GOING TO USE THESE NOTES
BUT THE SIMPLE FACT BECAUSE
THIS BILL SPEAKS TO THE HEART
AND THE VERY ESSENCE. OF THE
COMMUNITY WHICH I REPRESENT
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENTS AND AGAIN
I'M SPEAKING OF THE FOUR POLICE
OFFICER THOSE IT DOES WHEN THE
EIGHTIES AND EVERYBODY WAS
RUSHING TO PUTTING PEOPLE IN IN
JAIL INCARCERATE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. AND NOW
REPRESENTING OF A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN REACHED OUR
SERRATED ARE REPRESENTING THE
SIX PORTERS AGAIN IS THAT A
CALIFORNIA REALIZING THAT OUT
ON THE BLACK BROWN INDIVIDUALS
WHO RECEIVE THESE KINDS OF SIT
INS ENHANCEMENT. IN ADDITION TO
THAT. THIS BILL AGAIN THIS WILL
BRING PEOPLE'S ATTENTION SB ONE
THIRTY SIX SEEKS TO SAVE MONEY
OUR FUTURE COSTS CERTAINLY THE
OF. THE DEPARTMENT OF ANSWERED
ALREADY ESTIMATED THAT WHAT
KIND OF A STATE WE WILL SAVE IF
WE CHANGE IN THIS BILL PASSED
ON THE FIRST YEAR TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS THE SECOND YEAR
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR OVER SIXTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS SO WE SAVE MONEY. BY
ONE PASSING THIS BILL SB ONE
THIRTY SAFE AND TAKING DOT
TAKING THOSE RESOURCES AND
PLACING THEM INTO DIVERSION
PROGRAMS PROGRAMS TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS ENHANCING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND ALSO I'M
CREATING. OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS GOING TO CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES. THAT IS THE
RIGHT WAY TO GO WE HAVE TO
START DOING THINGS DIFFERENTLY
AS MY. COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES ALREADY ARTICULATED A
NEW. COLLEAGUES I JUST WANT TO
BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL
WOULD DO SO WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
WE ARE VOTING FOR. UNDER
EXISTING LAW IF A PERSON
COMMITS A PRIOR FELONY FOR
WHICH THEY ARE INCARCERATED.
AND THEY SERVICE SENTENCE AND
THEN THEY COMMIT ANOTHER FELONY.
AND THAT PERSON IS THEN
CONVICTED. AND A JUDGE THEN
FINDS IN IT THE JUDGE'S
SENTENCING DISCRETION THAT IS
APPROPRIATE THE JUDGE CAN
IMPOSE A ONE YEAR SENTENCE
ENHANCEMENT AND I SHOULD NOTE
FOR THE RECORD THAT IN MANY
CASES THAT LEADS TO ONLY 5280%
85% OF THAT TIME BEING ACTUALLY
SERVED WHEN YOU ACCOUNT FOR
CREDITS. IF THEY BEHAVE
THEMSELVES WHILE INCARCERATED
THIS BILL WOULD ELIMINATE THAT
ONE YEAR ENHANCEMENT. IT WOULD
ELIMINATE THAT JUDICIAL
DISCRETION. AND LOOK I SURE
CONCERNED ABOUT PRISON
OVERCROWDING I GET IT. FOR A
LONG TIME WE HAD A LOCK THEM
ALL UP APPROACH. THAT LED TO IN
JUSTICE IN IT WHAT DO WAY TO
CSUS OUR RESOURCES THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT PARTICULARLY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WITH
DRUG ADDICTION THEY'RE BEING
LOCKED UP FOR SENSUALLY HAVING.
HEALTH ISSUE AN ADDICTION. BUT
WE'RE PAST THAT NOW. THAT IS
BEEN SHOWN TO BE UNWORKABLE.
AND IT'S ON JUST BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
SOME PEOPLE CERTAINLY DESERVE
DIVERSION. THEY DESERVE
TREATMENT THEY NEED MENTAL
HEALTH CARE. THEY DESERVE
PROBATION THAT IS CERTAINLY
TRUE BUT SOME PEOPLE ARE ALSO
DANGEROUS. AND THEY DO HORRIBLE
THINGS OTHERS. A RATIONAL
PUBLIC SAFETY POLICY THAT I
WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU WE SHOULD
BE TRYING TO ACHIEVE IS TO
SEPARATE OUT. THOSE THAT ARE
FUELED. BY DICTION ARE FUELED
BY MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS AND
GIVE THEM HELP. FROM THOSE THAT
ARE PREDATORY AND DANGEROUS AND
THE PREDATORY AND DANGEROUS
FOLKS SOMETIMES NEED TO BE
LOCKED UP. TO KEEP THE REST OF
A SAFE AND TO KEEP THEIR
VICTIMS SAFE. THAT'S WHY I HAVE
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL TODAY I
HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHOR I WORK WITH THEM A LOT
ON DIFFERENT PIECES EVEN ON
PUBLIC SAFETY LEGISLATION WE
JUST DON'T SEE. EYE TO EYE ON
THIS ONE. OUR THIS IS
ENHANCEMENTS TYPICALLY APPLIED
IS BY DEFINITION IT'S APPLIED
TO REPEAT OFFENDERS ONLY. IT'S
OFTEN APPLIED TO. REPEAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OFFENDERS AND
I WANT TO FOCUS ON THAT AS AN
EXAMPLE SO WE ALL UNDERSTAND
WHAT WE'RE VOTING FOR TODAY. I
MAY BE REPEAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OFFENDERS IN MY PROFESSIONAL
LIFE. I PUT SOME OF THEM AWAY
I'VE DEFENDED SOME OF THEM. IF
YOU ARE INCARCERATED FOR FELONY
LEVEL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND YOU
SERVE TIME AND YOU GET OUT AND
COMMIT ANOTHER OFFENSE A FELONY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I BELIEVE THE
JUDGE SHOULD HAVE THE
DISCRETION TO ENHANCE YOUR
SENTENCE BY YEAR WHY. BECAUSE
OF YOUR REPEAT VIOLENT AND ANTI
SOCIAL BEHAVIOR THERE IS A
BIGGER RISK FOR YOU TO RE
OFFEND. THERE IS A BIGGER
DANGER TO YOUR VICTIM AND TO
OTHERS. THAT. PROTECTS THE
PUBLIC AND THAT PROTECTS YOUR
VICTIM IF YOU'VE EVER LOOKED IN
THE EYES OF THE DVD VICTIM AND
SEEN THE TEARS AND SEEN THE
FEAR. OKAY AND SEE THAT THE
CYCLE OF ABUSE IN ITS TRAGIC
HUMAN FORM. IF YOU LOOK IN
THEIR EYES THEN YOU KNOW WHAT I
MEAN. AND IF YOU HAVEN'T MAYBE
YOU DON'T. BUT THAT IS A REAL.
SO I ASK YOU PLEASE LEAVE THE
DISCRETION WITH THE JUDGE.
WE'VE IT'S ON THE BOOKS SO CAN
BE USED AS A TOOL TO PROTECT
PEOPLE BECAUSE FOR THAT VICTIM.
THAT YEAR. THAT YEAR IS A YEAR
THAT THEY FEEL SAFE AND SECURE
AND THEY'RE PROTECTED. PLEASE
CONSIDER THAT YOUR VOTE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVA.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I DON'T THINK MY
COLLEAGUES JUST SPOKE IT'S
INTERESTING HAVE YOU SEEN HIM
HAVE YOU LOOKED IN THEIR EYES
HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO. ALL THE
COPPER THIRTY YEARS I WENT TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALLS MY
FIRST CALL THE HOSPITAL BIRTH
YOU RICK BURGESS THE ROOM A
WOMAN HAD BEEN BEAT WITH A PAIR
JUMPER CABLES BY HER HUSBAND. I
THINK BLACK AND BLUE BEFORE BUT
NO YOU CAN BE YELLOW. ON HER
ENTIRE BODY FELONY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. IS THIS YEAR A LOT
ABOUT MONEY AND STUFF BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT. TO GO AROUND BEING
ON YOUR SPOUSE. WITH TALKING
GREAT BODILY INJURY. YOUR BEING
YOUR KID. YOU'RE BEING OLD
PEOPLE. YOU DON'T GET A PASS ON
THAT. THAT'S THE THINK ABOUT
WE'VE DONE AB ONE ONLINE PROP
47-57. PEOPLE STILL DO THINGS
YOU HAVE THAT PEOPLE TO DO
THINGS THIS WOULD NOT TALK
ABOUT DRUG CRIMES ARE SMALL
CRIMES IS A VERY SERIOUS
CRIMES. UNDER THE CURRENT
SYNCING JUDGES HAVE DISCRETION
THE DJS MAY REFLECT MAY MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS DO DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS BUT ULTIMATELY THE
JUDGE DECIDES. WHETHER REASON
DOESN'T HAVE TO NOT THE JUDGE
HAS A WHOLE FILE THERE KNOWS
THE PERSON'S BACKGROUND HISTORY
THERE PRIOR CRIMES. OKAY SO
DON'T SAY THAT IN HALF FOR YOU
FROM LA YOUR OWN DA SAYING THIS
IS NOT GOOD. THE FEELING NUMBER
THAT YOU'RE DA SAYING THIS.I
HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR THE
MINUTE FOR THE MEMBER THAT'S
BRINGS FOR FRANCE F. THIS BILL.
BY THE HARDEST WORKING MEMBER
IN THE LEGISLATURE THAT REALLY
WORKS AS A BILL. ON THIS ONE
JUST DOESN'T GET IT. WE GOT TO
FIX IT. THINK ABOUT THIS THESE
CRIMES ALSO PHONY STALKING A
CRIME YOU THE CONNECTED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. THESE CRIMES
INVOLVED TYPICALLY WOMEN
CHILDREN. AND THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT ONE CAUCUS IN HERE.
THOSE CRIMES AGAINST THEM. IT
GOES ON ALL THE TIME. I HAVEN'T
HEARD ONE PERSON SAY LAWSPEAKER
TALK ABOUT IT BUT VERY FEW.
TALK ABOUT VICTIMS. WHAT THE
OKAY. IS THAT OKAY TO PUT CAN
HOT SCALDING HOT WATER. IT GOES
ON EVERY DAY. THINK ABOUT THAT
THINK ABOUT TALKING TO A VICTIM
AND I'VE DONE THAT HUNDREDS OF
TIMES DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIM.
THAT HAD THEIR **** WHIPPED.
THAT IS NOT OKAY. SOME FOLKS
NOT EVERYONE HAVE A REPEAT
HISTORY OF DOING THAT. A PASS
DON'T GET A PASS ON THAT
DEFENDING. SO WHEN YOU'RE
ENHANCEMENT YEAH YOU MAY DO
HALF OF THAT THAT'S HOW IT IS.
TALK ABOUT MONEY ANYTHING DONE
TO A KID I DON'T CARE WHAT IT
COSTS YOU DON'T GET A BREAK YOU
DON'T GET A PASS WHY DID YOU
CAN PASS THESE TYPE OF PEOPLE
THAT THAT IS THAT IS INSANE
MITCHELL HIT YOUR HEAD AGAINST.
THE DAM WALL. IT IS NOT OKAY.
WHO IS A STAND UP FOR KIDS.
WOMEN AN ELDER WHO ABUSE THOSE
PEOPLE. IT'S NOT EASY I WANT TO
BE LOCKED UP. BUT FOR CERTAIN
CRIMES THERE'S GONNA BE
ACCOUNTABILITY AT SOME POINT
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT'S A FREE
PASS DO WHATEVER YOU WANT THERE
IS THERE ACCOUNTABILITY THE
BOTTOM LINE IS MOST FOLKS DON'T
DO THESE CRIMES IT NEVER
HAPPENS THE MOST FOLKS. BUT
PERHAPS A DEAL WITH THE GUILT
HELP. FIX RECIDIVISM RATE HELLO
RUN THE BUSES IN RATE. IS HIGH
WE DON'T WE'RE NOT FIXING THAT
ADDRESS THAT. ON BILL HAS NO
WHILE WE WITH WHAT THE JUDGES
TO HAVE DISCRETION ON BILL BUT
ALL THE CABS CHRISTIAN ON THIS
WE'RE TALKING TO BOTH SIDES OF
OUR MOUTHS. WHICH ONE WE PICK
ON. SERIOUSLY GIVE A DOES THIS
QUESTION HAS A RIGHT NOW THIS
BILL TAKES IT AWAY. YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU GO TO THESE CRIMES
THESE CALLS YOU WANT TO CRY. HE
GOES ON EVERY DAY LOOK AT YOUR
FILES GONNA CALL SOMETIME GOING
AWRY LONG. IF YOU A VICTIM SAY
HOW THEY FEEL. SOME WOMAN
CRYING SOME KID CRY. IT IS NOT
FUN THIS IF YOU HAVE KIDS. THIS
ONE THAT YOUR KID WILL BE OKAY.
YOU GIVE A PASS. NO SO ARE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON THIS. THANK YOU
MISTER COBER DR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'D TO RISE AS A PROUD
CO AUTHOR SB ONE THIRTY SIX.
DON'T BE DECEIVED SB ONE THIRTY
SIX IS A NARROW INCREMENTAL
BILL AND IT IS NOT A RADICAL BE
BUT AS POINTED OUT BY THE LA
TIMES AND OTHER NEWSPAPERS IT
IS AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BILL.
YOU KNOW I UP. ONE OF THE
TRAGEDIES OF SERVING ON THE ON
MANY OF THE COMMITTEES
PARTICULAR THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
IS IT TO HAVE A TENDENCY YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT
WHERE WE- PUT OUR RESOURCES AND
OUR TIME AND OUR ENERGY. AND
SURELY INCREASING PEOPLE'S TIME
IN PRISON HAS COST US I'M A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT I WOULDN'T BE
OPPOSED TO THAT IF IT ALSO IF
IT PROVIDED US WITH SAFETY AND
SECURITY. AND IT CREATED A
SYSTEM THAT WAS AFFECTED.
THAT'S PART NOT A PERSON ON
THIS FLOOR WHO BELIEVES OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM IS AFFECTED.
THAT WE ACCOMPLISHING THE GOAL
OF RESTORING PEOPLE BACK TO
BEING LAW ABIDING CITIZENS AND
THAT WE'RE GIVING THEM WHAT
THEY NEED TO FUNCTION WHEN THEY
LEAVE. WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS
MADE OURSELVES LOOK GOOD
BECAUSE WERE HARD ON CRIME. AND
HIT THE OTHER FACTS OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING. AND SO WHEN YOU
SERVE ON A BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
YOU HAVE TO GIVE AN ADDITIONAL
BILLION DOLLARS. TO THE PRISON
SYSTEM THAT IS INEFFECTIVE.
THAT IS REALLY WHERE HOUSING
SOULS AND NOT REALLY MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IT IS DIFFICULT.
THIS BILL IS VERY NARROW
COMPARED TO THE OTHER BILLS
WE'VE HAD IN THE PAST. WE CAN
TALK ABOUT VARIOUS ISSUES AND
MOST PEOPLE LIKE TO HARP ON THE
ISSUE OF WHAT OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. AND I SEE THE MESSAGE
VIOLENCE UP CLOSE AND PERSONAL
WHEN I SERVED ON A COUPLE
BOARDS ABOUT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CENTER SO I'M NOT A PERSON WHO
GIVES A LOT OF SLACK TO THOSE
WHO ARE COMMITTING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. BUT REST ASSURED THAT
THE JUDGE STILL MEANS UNDER THE
LAW THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO A
VARIETY OF SENTENCE THINGS
THAT'S THE- THIS HAS NOT
CHANGED THEY CAN GIVE TO THREE
OR FOUR YEARS SO THEY HAVE A
CHOICE OF THE LAW THE MIDDLE
AND HIGH. FOR FIRST OFFENDERS
BUT SECOND OFFENDERS THEY HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOUR TO FOUR
AND FIVE YEARS SO PEOPLE STILL
GET GREATER SENTENCING IF THEY
OF COMMITTEE SEC DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FOR THE SECOND TIME.
AND THAT IS NOT TAKEN AWAY IN
THIS BILL SO REST ASSURED THAT
IS NOT TAKEN WHEN WE HEAR ALL
THE HORROR STORIES AND THAT IS
NOT THE CASE. THEY ALSO HAVE IF
THEY'RE CONVICTED OF A FELONY
ABUSE OF CHILDREN THIS TO ALSO
HAS HIGHER SENTENCING DEPENDING
UPON WHETHER THE FIRST SECOND
CHANCE. AT IS YOUR TANK. THIS
BILL. SO WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
OFTENTIMES IS A PER TWO PEOPLE
COMMITTED COMMITTING A FELONY.
AND ONE GETS PROBATION AND
ANOTHER GET SENTENCE. AND WE
KNOW WHAT THE ETHNICITY OF
THOSE TWO PEOPLE ARE. MORE THAN
LIKELY ONE IS WHITE AND ONE IS
BLACK. AND WHEN THEY COME BACK
THE SECOND TIME IF THEY COMMIT
THIS FELONY OFFENSE NOW THIS
PERSON WHO IS INCARCERATED YES
ADDITIONAL YEARS WITH THE
PERSON WHO COMMITTED THE SAME
OFFENSE AND GOT PROBATION
BECAUSE THEY THEY HAD MONEY OR
CONNECTIONS THEY'VE BEEN START
OFF WITH THE LESSER OFFENSE. WE
KNOW THE SYSTEM IS CORRUPT IT
WAS DESIGNED TO TRY TO HARNESS
ALL THE PROBLEMS WE HAD IN THE
WOMAN O OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM WITHOUT THINKING ABOUT
THE HUMAN COST. AND WE STE THIS
IS A NARROW BILL MUCH NEARER
WITH MANY PEOPLE WHAT WHAT IS
IT TO BE AND THERE ARE THAN
PRIOR BILLS A DEALS WITH SENSE
AND HANSON THIS THE BASICALLY
TALKS ABOUT BASICALLY. ONE YEAR
IN EXCELLENT. THE CHILD ABUSE
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ARE TAKEN
OUT AND THEIR HANDLE SEPARATELY
IN A DIFFERENT SECTION OF PENAL
CODE AND IS NOT AFFECTED BY
THIS BECAUSE THEY ALREADY HAVE.
THE BUILT ON ENHANCEMENTS BASED
ON WHO'S COMMITTED THE CRIME IN
AND WHETHER IT'S MORE THAN ONE
TIME. I ASK YOU TO SOMETIMES
YOU KNOW DO SOME DIFFICULT
THINGS. LIKE THINK ABOUT FOLKS
RELATED TO YOU WHO MIGHT BE IN
THE SAME SITUATION. ONE
FAMILIES OF YOUR COULD MEMBERS
OF YOUR COMMUNITY. AND THINK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
SOMETIMES ARE ADDING ON YEARS
AND YEARS OF TWO PEOPLE'S
LIVES. THAT WHERE THEY HAVE NOT
COMMITTED THE WORST CRIME IN
THE WORLD. BUT WITH BASED ON
THIS THERE GIVEN THE ISSUE OF
ENHANCEMENT. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
OUR SYSTEM TREATS PEOPLE OF
COLOR DIFFERENTLY AND IT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE MADE UP THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT IS RECOGNIZED
IN THE- IN THE LEGAL COMMUNITY.
AND YET THEY HAVE NO ANSWER TO
THE PROBLEM. WE GET THE HARDEST
IN SAYING IF CHOICE BETWEEN
THEM I'M A MISDEMEANOR OR
FELONY NORMALLY IT'S A FELONY
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR. IF THEY
HAVE A CHOICE BETWEEN TWO THREE
AND FIVE YEARS IS NORMALLY FIVE
YEARS. WE'VE SEENTHIS TIME AND
TIME AGAIN AND IT IS NOT IN ANY
WAY IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
LIFE. THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE DESIGNED MAYES LOVER ANY
SAFER. SO I WOULD ASK THAT YOU
CAREFULLY THINK ABOUT THIS THIS
IS A ONE YEAR AND IT DOES NOT
APPLY TO CHILD WHO'S IN IT. THE
POP TO THE- VIOLENCE SO ALL
THIS DRAMA THAT WE CURRENTLY TO
FEAR FOLKS INTO DOING WHAT WE
KNOW IN OUR HEARTS NEEDS TO BE
CHANGED. WE NEED TO THROW THAT
OUT AND RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
A NARAL SENSIBLE. RECOGNIZED.
BY MANY OF YOUR LOCAL
NEWSPAPERS AS SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO BEGIN TO DO. IN ORDER
TO MOVE US FORWARD IN THIS
STATE SO WE'RE NOT KNOWN AS A
PERSON AT THE STATE WITH THE
LONGEST. RECORDS OF PEOPLE
BEING INCARCERATED. AND YET THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF RECIDIVISM
BECAUSE OUR SYSTEM IS BROKEN IT
DOES NOT WORK. AND AS THEY SAY
THE PEOPLE. SAYING PLAYING OVER
AND OVER AGAIN OBVIOUSLY MUST
BE INSANE EXPECT DIFFERENT
RESULTS. THANK YOU DOCTOR
ROBERT. MR GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE THIRTY SIX TODAY. AND DO SO
VERY CAREFULLY AS CO FOUNDER OF
THE CENTRAL COUNTY FAMILY
JUSTICE CENTER. THAT IS LOCATED
IN CONCORD THAT SPECIALIZES AND
ASSIST VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. I AM VERY CAREFUL TO
MAKE SURE THAT VICTIMS. VOICES
ARE HEARD THE VICTIMS ARE
REPRESENTED. THAT VICTIMS CAN
NO WITH THE SURETY AND
CERTAINTY. THAT THEY ARE SAFE
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES. AND JUST
I WENT TO CLARIFY AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS ONE YOUR
ENHANCEMENT. IS PUTTING VIC IS
A DETRIMENT ACTUALLY THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. THE ANNUAL
LOOK AT THE LAW AS IT IS
WRITTEN. IT APPEARS AS THOUGH
AND JUST FOR CLARITY OF SOMEONE
COULD IN THEIR SPEECH AFTER ME
MAKE SURE OF IT JUST FOR
CLARITY IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THERE'S A THREE YEAR
ENHANCEMENT FOR A LE SECOND
FELONY OR FOR ANOTHER FELONY
BEHIND THE FIRST ONE. AND SO
THERE ARE ALREADY STRONGER
ENHANCE ITS THAT ARE UNAFFECTED
BY BILL WHEN IT COMES TO CHILD
ABUSE EXACTLY THE SAME THING
THERE ARE RIGHT ALREADY
ENHANCEMENTS IN EXISTENCE THAT
WHAT IMPACT THESE FELONS OR THE
CRIMINALS THAT ARE FAR. MORE
SEVERE THAN THIS ONE YOUR
ENHANCEMENT THAT I BELIEVE
UNDERSTANDING CORRECTLY IS
RARELY USED SO JUST FOR CLARITY
I LIKE THAT THAT IN A CLOSING
STATEMENT. THANK YOU MISTER
GRAYSON MISSED CONSOLIDATES YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO BE HONEST I HAD CONCERNS AS
I'VE HEARD MANY. EXPRESSED ON
THIS OR- BECAUSE I DO WORRY AND
THOSE OF YOU WHO'VE SIR WITH ME
LONG ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT I
PARTICULARLY WORRY ABOUT. FOLKS
WHO HAVE COMMITTED CRIMES THAT
ARE LIKELY TO RE OFFEND AND
THOSE ARE. USUALLY SEX CRIMES
SEX CRIMES IN PARTICULAR
AGAINST CHILDREN. AND SO
DESPITE ENHANCEMENTS IN OTHER
PARTS OF LAW I WANT TO NOTE
THAT IN APPROPRIATIONS WE
ADDED. WE ADDED AMENDMENTS TO
EXCLUDE ANY PERSON WITH A PRIOR
CONVICTION FOR RAPE AGGRAVATED
SEXUAL ASSAULT OF A CHILD
SODOMY ORAL COPULATION. CHILD
MOLESTATION CONTINUOUS SEXUAL
ABUSE OF A CHILD SEXUAL
PENETRATION AND ASSAULT AND
KIDNAPPING WITH INTENT TO
COMMIT A SEX CRIME. THERE ARE
SOME CRIMES. THAT PEOPLE
COMMIT. THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHY
THEY COMMIT AND WE DON'T KNOW
HOW TO REFORM THEM OR TO FIX
THEM AND SO WHEN THEY'RE CAUGHT
AGAIN WE WANT TO ENSURE. THAT
THERE ARE ENHANCEMENTS I THINK
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM CONCORD
SAID WE HAVE OTHER PARTS OF THE
CODE THAT ALSO DO THAT BUT WE
STILL EVEN CALLED OUT
EXCEPTIONS ON SEX CRIMES
ESPECIALLY SEX CRIMES AGAINST
CHILDREN. SO WITH THAT I FOUND
MYSELF COMFORTABLE ENOUGH. OF
COURSE TO ENSURE SOMETHING THAT
HAS BEEN USED IN A PERMIT FOR
YOU FASHION. LEE IN A WAY TO
ENSURE THAT MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE WHO ARE FROM BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES ARE LOCKED
UP. THAT I WAS COMFORTABLE WITH
DIFFERENTIATING BETWEEN WHAT
SOME PEOPLE COMMIT THIS CRIME
SOMETIMES A NECESSITY VERSUS.
AND BEAT YOU KNOW REHABILITATED
FROM AND CAN BE. IN ANY AND CAN
BE CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY IN THOSE WHICH I FEEL
LIKE THEY CAN'T SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. YOU MISS GONZALEZ MISTER
BONTA. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES I DO WANT TO
JUST CLARIFY A COUPLE OF ITEMS
I AM SPEAKING IN SUPPORT PLAN
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I
THINK THERE WAS SOME STATEMENTS
MADE THROUGHOUT THE TO THAT I
AM QUITE A LITTLE CONFUSED
HOUSE OF THE HAND HAND SMIT
THAT ALREADY EXIST. IN OUR
CRIMINAL LAW AND WILL CONTINUE
TO EXIST REGARDLESS OF SB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY SIX YOU PASS.
AND I WANT TO SPECIFICALLY
POINT OUT THE ENHANCEMENTS THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO EXIST
REGARDLESS OF SB ONE THIRTY SIX
RELATED TO REPEAT FELONY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND REPEAT.
OUR FELONY CHILD ABUSE TODAY A
PERSON CONVICTED OF FELONY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WITH A PRIOR
CONVICTION FOR THE SAME CRIME.
WITHIN SEVEN YEARS CAN BE GIVEN
A LONGER SENTENCE THAN SOMEONE
CONVICTED OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
FOR THE FIRST TIME. AND THAT
WON'T CHANGE UNDER SB ONE
THIRTY SIX THAT A PERSON ALSO
CONVICTED OF A FELONY CHILD
ABUSE WITH A PRIOR CONVICTION.
FOR THE SAME CRIME CAN BE
PUNISHED WITH FOUR YEAR
SENTENCE ENHANCEMENT. ON TOP
WITH UNDERLINED SENTENCE. AT
THE PRIOR OFFENSE OCCURRED IN
TEN YEARS BEFORE THE CURRENT
EVENTS AND AGAIN. THAT'S NOT
GONNA CHANGE ADDRESS BE ONE
THIRTY SIX SO THERE WERE SOME
STATEMENT IT'S WITH THE COP OUT
TO MY MIND. IF WE COME OUT
TAPIA SOMEONE DESPAIR FIGHT
WITH THE EXISTING LAW IS WHAT
IT WILL CONTINUE TO BE.
REGARDLESS OF SB THIRTY SIX
PASS THERE'S ALSO GONNA GET.
BOOKS I CAN CALL. IN HAND FOR
REPEAT VIOLENT CRIME OF UP TO
THREE YEARS. SO ARE COMING LOTS
FULL OF ANY SENSE TO THEM CAN
YOU BE THERE FOR THE THINGS
THAT YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY
INCLUDING DOMESTIC MY-
POLLUTING. THE BUTTE. INCLUDE
ALL. THE SAME SET OF FACTS. SHE
HAD THOSE THAT SPOKE IN
SUPPORT. BECAUSE IT'S NOT EASY
WHEN OPPOSITION. USES WHAT IS
OFTEN TIMES USED. IN IN THESE
TYPES OF WITH THESE TYPES OF
BILLS IS FEAR. AND I GET THAT
BECAUSE USING FEAR. MAKES A LOT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR US TO
ACTUALLY DO THE WORK THAT'S
pNECESSARY TO CREATE A JUSTICE
SYSTEM. THAT DOES WORK FOR
EVERYONE AND THAT'S FAIR. I'M
ASKING ALL YOU COLLEAGUES TO
ACTUALLY LOOK AT WHAT THIS BILL
ACTUALLY DOES NOT THE
ANECDOTAL. COMMENTS FROM THOSE
IN OPPOSITION. THAT SUGGEST
SOMEHOW THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO GET AWAY WITH THINGS. THAT
THAT THEY ARE FOUND GUILTY OF
WHICH IS SIMPLY. NOT TRUE. WE
KNOW. FOR EXAMPLE THAT IN THE-
A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES REYES
SPECIFIC TO. DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND CHILD ABUSE WELL. THERE'S
ALREADY. OF THE MECHANISMS.
THERE'S ALTERS ALTERNATIVE
SENTENCING FOR EXAMPLE. ON
THOSE THAT. ARE REPEAT ONLY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. PERPETRATORS
OF THREE YEAR LONGER THAN A
PERSON AT UNDER NOT TO MENTION
THAT IS GREAT. THE INJURY. IN
ADDITION A FIVE TOP OF THE
THANKS. SIMILAR. ENHANCE IS
BOTH SING ALONG TO SOLVE AS
WELL AS HANDS ON TOP APPLY TO
CHECK USE EASY TO SAY WELL
WE'RE GETTING RID OF THIS FOR
THOSE THAT PERPETRATE CHILD
ABUSE OR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
BECAUSE THAT NATURALLY PULLS
OUT ALL OF OUR HEARTSTRINGS WE
WANT TO PROTECT OUR CHILDREN WE
WANT TO PROTECT THOSE THAT ARE
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND- REMOVING SB ONE THIRTY SIX
DOES NOT PREVENT US FROM DOING
THAT IN FACT THE EXACT SAME
MECHANISM THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO
REPEAT OFFENDERS AND THE BIBLE
THE CHILD ABUSE AND NUMEROUS.
OTHER KINDS OF CON CONTINUE TO
BE ON THE BOOKS I CONTINUE TO
BE USED TO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE AND MAKE. SURE THAT
NO ONE. GETS A PASS. AND WE
KNOW. WELL AS MEN ABOUT OF OUR
COLLEAGUES DO HORRIBLE THINGS
AND- GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
ABLE. THINGS THEY DO NOW WHAT
THIS COMES DOWN TO QUITE SIMPLY
AN IBM I APPRECIATE OUR CLICK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM OAKLAND FOR
SPEAKING TO SOME OF THE
EXISTING ENHANCEMENTS THAT
AREN'T GOING ANYWHERE. THERE'S
OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY UP.
AND I KNOW THAT. TIMES WHAT'S
THAT SAY. WELL ARE WE DOING A
LOT ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
ARC CALLED FROM TORRANCE
INDICATES THAT HE UNDERSTANDS
OUR EFFORTS AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM HOWEVER. IGNORES
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
ENHANCEMENTS THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO PUNISH THOSE THAT PERPETRATE.
HEINOUS CRIMES AND VIOLENT
CRIMES. OVER DECADES CALIFORNIA
BECAME THE INCARCERATION
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD. THAT
DIDN'T HAPPEN BY ACCIDENT IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN BECAUSE ALL OF A
SUDDEN PEOPLE WERE SUDDENLY
CREEK COMMITTING MORE CRIMES
THAT HAPPEN BECAUSE OF
DECISIONS IN THIS BODY. IT WAS
IS THIS BODY THAT CREATED THE
INCARCERATION CAPITAL OF THE
WORLD. NOW BRICK BY BRICK WE'RE
TRYING TO REMOVE. THE
FOUNDATIONS OF. MASS
INCARCERATION WHILE MAINTAINING
THE FOUNDATION OF AN EQUITABLE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM YOU CAN
DO BOTH WE'VE BEEN MAKING OUR
BEST EFFORTS TO DO BOTH AND WE
KNOW THAT MANY OF THE ENHANCE
WAS THAT WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON
AGAIN OF THE HUNDRED FIFTY PLUS
WE'RE NOT GOING OUT FOR A
HUNDRED FIFTY ENHANCEMENTS
WE'RE GOING OUT FOR TARGETED.
THE ONE YEAR PRISON PRIOR
ENHANCEMENT BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A
BROADLY APPLICABLE ENHANCEMENT.
LET'S KEEP ALL THE SPECIFIC
ENHANCEMENTS THAT DEAL WITH
SPECIFIC CONDUCT SPECIFIC
REPEATED CONDUCT THE PROBLEM
WITH HAVING A BROUGHT IT HAS
BEEN LIKE THIS ONE YOUR
ENHANCEMENT IS THAT IT GETS
BROADLY USE AND NOT JUST
BECAUSE THOSE THAT DO HORRIBLE.
THINGS WHATEVER THAT MEANS AND
FOR OTHER PEOPLE. GET USED
ACROSS THE BOARD AGAINST
EVERYONE AND IT'S MOSTLY POOR
PEOPLE PEOPLE OF COLOR. WE KNOW
THAT YOU'RE FAR MORE LIKELY
THAT I SERVE JAIL. OR PRISON
TIME. IF YOU'RE A PERSONAL
COLOR IF YOU'RE POOR WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS JUDGES YOU HAVE ALL
THE SPECIAL YOU HAVE BIG GIVING
YOU A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ENHANCEMENTS NOT ONLY THAT YOU
CAN YOU CAN USE THE HIGHER TERM
UNDER SENTENCE UNDER SENTENCING
GUIDELINES YOU DON'T USE THE
LOW AND I HAD A ONE YEAR HAS
BEEN USED TO MAKE SURE USE THE
HIGHER TRIMTHAT'S A
PROVISIONAL PORTS TO THE TALK
ABOUT YOUR CRIMINAL HISTORY
THAT'S WHAT IS PUSH FOR. WE
KNOW THIS. AND I KNOW THIS I'VE
SEEN IT IN PRICE AFTER THAT
MISTER KALRA. THIS LINEUP. BY
ROOM THIS AND HAS A WE ARE IN
NO WAY MAKING OUR COMMUNITIES
ANY LESS SAFE I WERE IN NO WAY
TAKING AWAY THE TOOLS NECESSARY
FOR A JUDGE TO ADEQUATELY MAKE
SURE THAT A PUNISHMENT THE
CRIME AS SHE OR HE SEES IT
MISTER KALRA TIMES THAT PLEASE
I AM POOR YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
ENHANCEMENT AS WAS INDICATED BY
A COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
OTHER ENHANCES ARE FAR MORE
COMPLEX AND COMPLICATED THIS IS
QUITE A SIMPLE ONE THIS STILL
ALLOWS US TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE
HAVE A JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
WORKS FOR EVERYONE THANK YOU
CLERK WILL OPEN. THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DOES THAT
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS PRESERVATIVES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE.
REQUIRES FORTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WHERE WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE EYES FORTY ONE KNOWS
THIRTY THREE. MEASURE PASSES
.
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY IN FILE
ITEM FIFTY TWO FILE ITEM FIFTY
THREE AB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME REAL FUN
THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN AND OTHERS NOT RELATED
MEDICAL EVIDENCE OR
EXAMINATIONS. MR BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL SEEKS TO
IMPROVE THE AVAILABILITY
EFFICIENCY AND QUALITY OF
MEDICAL EVIDENCE YOUR
EXAMINATIONS FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS SENATE AMENDMENTS
RESOLVE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION AND REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER. KING IN
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESIRED VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY NO ZERO SENTIMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN WE WILL PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR
FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FORTY
SEVEN BY SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ
ANOTHER'S MACRO TO REPORT IT IS
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FIVE
FORTY SEVEN EMPOWERS JANITORIAL
WORKERS BY UTILIZING EXISTING
PEER COUNSELORS TO PROVIDE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT TRAINING.
ON HOW TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS
ON THE WORK. RECENT AMENDMENT
IN THE SENATE REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION BUT WE DO HAVE
SUPPORT FOR A BUNCH OF WONDER
WOMEN IN THE GALLERY AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GONZALES. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER. THAT'S NOT TRUE MR
GIPSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NON SPEAKER
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF FIVE AB FIVE FORTY SEVEN. AS
A FORMER STATE WHY POLITICAL
DIRECTOR FOR JUST FOR JANITORS
UNDER THE LATE PRESIDENT MY
GARCIA. I DON'T THINK THE
MEMBER OF SAN DIEGO OF A RING
THIS METAPHOR. YESTERDAY
MEMBERS I HAVE PERTINENT EACH.
WITH YOUR FINGERS AT THE- CODE
WAS OUTSIDE THE CAP. WHERE I
HEARD A YOUNG I HEARD MEN TELL
THEIR STORIES ABOUT THEIR OWN
SEXUAL ABUSE IN THE WORKPLACE
IT WAS OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR NOW
IN THESE BANDS BUT ALSO STAND
UP IN A LOUD VOICE MEN WHO'VE
BEEN SEXUALLY ABUSE HAVE BEEN
TAUGHT OR MEN PERIOD BE MACHO
BE STRONG YOU DO YOU KNOW
MENTIONS CRIED THINGS OF THAT
NATURE BUT TO HAVE THESE MEN
STAND UP. IN A LARGE VOICE YOU
TODAY AND TALK ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCES BUT ALSO HAVING IS
THAT THE COMES BEFORE US THAT
HELPS IN POWER AND. ALSO MAKE
SURE. THAT THE DID HAPPEN.
EDITORS ARE NOT VICTIMS. RIGHT
WAY TO GO MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I VOTE ON
A. B. FIVE FORTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER GIVE SEND SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER GONZALEZ TO MAKE
THEM. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. SEVEN AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCORD AND WE'LL MOVE BACK
UP. IN FILE ORDER. IN THE FILE
TO FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO A. B.
FIVE OH SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE OH SIX BY
SOME REMEMBER KALRA ACTUALLY TO
HEALTH FACILITIES. MISTER KALRA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. WHY NOT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER OF THE REQUESTED
APARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH CENTER
THE MEMBERS TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE OR SIX PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CLARITY ON THE CAUSATION
STANDARD FOR DETERMINING CLASS
DOUBLY VIOLATIONS SUBSTANTIAL
FACTOR AND APPLY A NEW PENALTY
SCHEDULE CLASS A VIOLATIONS
INVOLVING RESIDENTS A RESIDENT%
DEATH AMENDMENTS ALSO ADDS TO
THE ELEMENTS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT MUST PROVE ONE ISSUE
POSSIBLY BUT THE DEATH WAS A
POOR BE ABLE RESULT OF THE
VIOLATION IS CONSISTENT WITH
CURRENT CASE LAW AND IT'S THE
ABILITY FOR THE- JUST POUND THE
AMOUNTS. OF THE CONSUMER PRICE
AND. TENSION HEALTH FACILITIES
COP SOLICITATION DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES NETWORK. AND LEADING
AGE CALIFORNIA NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
STRIKES A BALANCE ON UPDATING A
CONFUSING CAUSATION STANDARD
AND ADJUSTING PENALTY AMOUNTS
STUCK THE ASTRONAUT ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
MOVEMENT IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AS ART ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS ONE THING AMENDMENTS ARE
CONVERTED BACK TO FILE ORDER
WE'LL MOVE TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
SIX AB. SIX HUNDRED THE CLERK
WILL READ. SO MIDDLE SIX
HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU AND ACTUALLY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT MR CHIU YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SB SIX HUNDRED IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE TO SEND THAT
THE MAMMON. OUR TECHNICAL AND
TERRIFYING IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR OPAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESIRED BOTH. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL LOW'S THE ROLAND
TALLY THAT ICE FIFTY FIVE NO
ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM FIFTY
SEVEN AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL A
TWENTY FOUR BY SOMEBODY RIVER
WOULD ANOTHER RECYCLING TO
BUSINESS SIR WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS IT AB EIGHT
TWENTY FOUR IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE FROM THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
EXPANDED THE TYPES OF
AGREEMENTS EXEMPT FROM THIS
BILL. DELETED THE REQUIREMENT
THE PARTY'S PROVED THAT THAT
PRO COMPETITIVE BENEFITS OF AN
AGREEMENT CAN BE ACHIEVED BY
LESS RESTRICTIVE MEANS I ASK
FOR YOUR CONCURRENCE IN IN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS I RESPECT.
BASS DRIVE UP. THANK YOU MISTER
WOULD TO SEEING AND HEARING.
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS NOTED
DESIRED MODE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT ICE
FIFTY KNOWS ONE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE EIGHTY
NINE NINETEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME PEOPLE NINE NINETEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
ANOTHER'S NECK LIKE A DRUG AND
ALCOHOL PROGRAMS. PETRIE-NORRIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AB NINE NINETEEN TO ESTABLISH
ADDITIONAL TO TOOLS TO PREVENT
BODY BURKE GREEN SCHEMES AND
THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
INDUSTRY. SENATE AMENDMENTS
LIMIT HOW SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT FACILITIES OFFER
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION AS
INDUCEMENTS FOR TREATMENT
AMENDMENTS ALSO ADDRESSED
CHAPTER IN OUT ISSUES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
HE MISSED PETRIE-NORRIS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS NOTED IS ERA. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING
VOTE I SIXTY FOUR NEW ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN
FILE ITEM SIXTY AB TEN TEN THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE TEN
TEN BY SOME REMEMBERED WATER
GARCIA AN ACCOLADE HOUSING IN
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION ARE FOR
MR GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MAY BE GOING
COLLEAGUES A. B. TEN TEN IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE. SENTIMENT
IS PROVIDES TECHNICAL AGES IN
ORDER TO APPROPRIATELY LAMENT
THE BILL. THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
DULY CONSTITUTED. IT TOO AIDED.
GOVERNING BODIES OF A NATIVE
AMERICAN RESERVATION RANCHERIA.
TO BECOME ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS
TO PARTICIPATE IN SPECIFIED FOR
BY HOUSING PROGRAMS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MR GARCIA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. BY
LETTING SIXTY ONE AB ELEVEN
FORTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL LIMóN FORTY SIX
BY SOME REMEMBER BERMAN KNACK
RELATED PRIVACY MR BERMAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A. B.
LOOKING FORTY SIX WOULD MAKE IT
CLEAR THAT A NEW VOTE. THAT A
NEW MOTOR VEHICLE DEALER MAY
RETAIN VEHICLE AND OWNERSHIP
INFORMATION IN ORDER TO SHARE
IT WITH AN AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURER FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ENABLING WARRANTY WORK OR IN
MANUFACTURERS RECALL THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ENSURE THAT THE BILL
WAS NARROWLY TAILORED TO ONLY
ACCOMPLISH THIS OBJECTIVE AND
NOTHING MORE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER BERMAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER. OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS NOTED AS OUR DEVOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. FULLER WELL TO LOSE THE
ROLE AND TALENTED ICE FIFTY SIX
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM SIXTY
TWO AB TWELVE FIFTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
FIFTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER TING
AND ACTIVATE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT'S THIRTEEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MEMBERS
BECAUSE AB TWELVE FIFTEEN
PROHIBITS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES FROM USING BIOMETRIC
SCANNERS IN. SPEECH RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE IN BODY CAMERAS IN THE
SENATE WE TOOK AMENDMENTS TO
SUNSET THE LEGISLATION IN THREE
YEARS SO IT'S ONLY FOR THREE
YEARS AS WE ALL KNOW FACIAL
RECOGNITION SOFTWARE RIGHT NOW
IS GREATLY INACCURATE. WE
DEMONSTRATED THIS USING A TEST
WHERE WE LOOKED AT ALL OF OUR
PICTURES IN THE LEGISLATURE
CROSS REFERENCE TO WITH A MUG
SHOT BOOK AND FOUND THAT OF THE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY OF US OVER
TWENTY SIX OF US WERE
MISIDENTIFIED AS CRIMINALS.
AGAIN BECAUSE THE SOFTWARE IS
NOT READY FOR PRIMETIME WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO PUT A
PAUSE SURE THAT WE DON'T MISS
USER FALSELY ACCUSE PEOPLE OR
WORSE FALSELY ARREST PEOPLE ARE
VERY PROUD TO HAVE. SUPPORT
FROM THE LA TIMES AS WELL AS
THE OC BUT MR. GAS FOR AYE VOTE
ON A. B. TWELVE FIFTEEN. MR
TAKING SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THAT WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
IZZARD VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE IT THIS REQUIRES FORTY
ONE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE
.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY TWO
NEWS EIGHTEEN. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT REAL
SIX TO A THE FONG NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO ME
TOMORROW UPON CALL THE CHAIR IN
A ROOM TO BE DETERMINED
GOVERNMENT ORGAN GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION TO HEAR A. B. IT
WOULD AND- A. B. EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FIVE GOVERNMENT ORGAN
ISSUE COMMITTEE AND LABOR
EMPLOYMENT HERE A. B. FORTY.
KAMLAGER-DOVE WITHOUT OBJECTION
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX AND WITHDRAWAL SB SEVEN
FORTY NINE DORADO FROM THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IN ORDER
THE BILL TO THE THIRD READING
FILE. THANK YOU. THERE'S A-
MISTER FLOOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER WE
WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
MEMBERS MISTER CALDERON MOVES
MIS READ SECONDS. THAT THE
RULES BE SUSPENDED. CLICK WELL
OPEN OF ALL. MEMBERS MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MR FLOOR IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE. AND IT IS THE
PROCEDURAL VOTE MISTER CALDERON
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE MISTER
FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
ON THE VERGE VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FIFTY SIX KNOWS SEVENTEEN. THE
MOTION CARRIES. MEMBERS ARE
TURNING TO BUSINESS ON THE FILE
WE WILL PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY THREE.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AND
ACRYLATE OR ONLY GAS MR HOLDEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE. THERE ARE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF OLD AND
POTENTIALLY LEAKING OIL AND GAS
WELLS IN CALIFORNIA. AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WOULD
MAKE INFORMATION OR GAS LEAKS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. IN ABOUT
EVEN IN THAT IS IMPORTANT GOING
THE SIZE AND SCOPE WITH
EMISSIONS FROM AN OLD DESERTED
WELL. LIKE I. JUST PRODUCTION
IT'S ALL RIGHT. GOOD AND HOW'S
IT IS OIL AND GAS WILL LEAK
POLLUTION. POTENTIAL EMISSIONS
FROM IDA WELLS INCLUDE METHANE
AND BENZENE. NOTHING IS A
CLIMATE CHANGE GAS MANY TIMES
MORE POWERFUL THAN CARBON
DIOXIDE WHILE OTHER CO ADMITTED
AIR POLLUTANTS LIKE BENZENE CAN
CAUSE CANCER. I DON'T AND
DESERTED IT WELL TEN AND DO
LEAK AND WHEN THEY DO IT CAN
RESULT IN EMISSIONS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO CLIMATE CHANGE IN
AND DAY IN PUBLIC HEALTH. I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU MISTER
HOLDEN. SEEN ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES FORTY
SIX KNOWS FOR THE AMENDMENTS
ARE AGREEMENT. WILL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN SIXTY
FOUR THE CLERK WILL READ.
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN
AN ACCOLADE CONSUMER PRIVACY MR
BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SB FIFTEEN SIXTY
FOURS BACK ON CONCURRENCE FOR
THE PURPOSES OF RECEIVING AND
RESPONDING TO SEE CPA REQUESTS
EVERY FIFTEEN SIXTY FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE A BUSINESS THAT
OPERATES EXCLUSIVELY ONLINE AND
HAS A DIRECT RELATIONSHIP WITH
CONSUMERS. FROM A COLLECT
PERSONAL INFORMATION FROM TO
WRITE AN EMAIL ADDRESS LOWER
TOLL FREE PHONE NUMBER SENATE
AMENDMENTS NAY THE BILL AND
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER I SEE NO
DISCLOSE QUESTION ON THE ITEM.
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL. CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO SEVEN MINUTES ARE
CONCURRENT. MOVIE THAT FILE
ITEM SIXTY SIX ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER
THREE OF US AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE AND LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES. THREE OF US YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE PLACE THE PROGRAM UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN TO REMOVE THE AIR
QUALITY STANDARD WHERE BY
INCREASING. RURAL AREAS OF THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO QUALIFY FOR
FUNDING ENSURES THAT PRIORITY
WILL BE GIVEN TO SCHOOLS WITH I
AM ON STUDENTS ON FREE AND
REDUCED LUNCH AND BASED ON
EXISTING ACCESS TO GREEN SPACE.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
RECEIVE BI PARTISAN SUPPORT. AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IS
SUPPORTED BY THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND CALIFORNIA BY
RENTAL JUST LINE STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION. CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF BLACK SCHOOL
LEADERS THE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
UNIFIED. SCHOOL DISTRICT JUST
THE NAME OF THE ITEM THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES ICE FIFTY
FIVE KNOWS THREE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
MEMBERS THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
SEVEN BY SOME MEMBER WEBER AN
ACCOLADE TO EMPLOYMENT DOCTOR
WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED MAYES
MISTER SPEAKER AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN IS BACK UP FROM
THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE
THERE WAS SOME AMENDMENTS MADE
IN IT TO REMOVE THE PENALTY
THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED FOR
EMPLOYEES WHO FAIL TO GIVE
ADEQUATE NOTICE. OF IT ENDING
RELOCATION AS WELL AS A PLACE
FORTY TO WAIT CALL CENTERS EL
IN ELIGIBILITY AWAY FROM THE
LABOR COMMISSION AND TO THE
APPROPRIATE AGENCY OF THERE
WERE OTHER CLARIFYING AND NOT
SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES THIS BILL
IS DESIGNED TO HOLD WE CREATE
SOME FITNESS AND TO SAVE JOBS
IN CALIFORNIA WITH OUR CALLS.
AIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES AYE AYES FORTY FOUR
KNOWS FOURTEEN. THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
NUMBER THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN THIRTY.
COOKERY ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GONZALEZ IMMACULATELY
TRANSPORTATION SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
AS A LOCAL DISTRICT BILL
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE WERE
TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS INSULTS CENA
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON AND
THE CLERK WILL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CRACKLE CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTES HIGHS FIFTY KNOWS
EIGHT THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
COMPARED
. MEMBERS WE STILL HAVE
A FEW ITEMS ON THE CONCURRENCE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS. MEMBERS
WILL GO BACK ON THE FILE TO
FOLLOW NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY SIX SPORT
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME MIDDLE
AGED SIXTY FOUR BY SOME
REMEMBER MULLIN ACCOLADE TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR MR NONE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN I AUTHORED AB TWO
FORTY NINE WHICH ALLOWED VOTERS
TO MORE EASILY SEE THE TOP
FUNDERS OF BALLOT MEASURES AN
INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURE ADS.
TELEVISION ADS ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO SHOW TO SCHOOLS OF LISTING
THE TOP THREE FUNDERS OF THAT
AT AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
LAST YEAR EXTENDED DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS SOCIAL MEDIA
POLITICAL ADVERTISING SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF THAT WAS TO LAWS THE
FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION RAISE A NUMBER OF
SMALL ISSUES THAT NEEDED
FURTHER CLARIFICATION
AMENDMENTS TAKE IN THE SENATE
WERE MINOR AND ADDRESSED
CAPTURING CONCERNS AB EIGHT SIX
FOUR HAS RECEIVED STRONG
PARTISAN SUPPORT ASK FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN.
SEEN OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION THE CLERK WILL. ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE HIGHER TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
THREE KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE AND
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS WHILE WE'RE PREPARING
TO FINISH OFF OUR WORK THIS
AFTERNOON OUT ENTERTAIN SOME
VOTE CHANGES AT THIS TIME IF
YOU'D LIKE TO. REGISTER VOTE
CHANGE PLEASE PLACE YOUR
MICROPHONE IN THE AIR BE
RECOGNIZED. MISTER GRAYSON
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR VOTE
CHANGE GRAYSON VOTE CHANGE AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE NO TO A
HIGH. CHANGES WILL BE MEMBER
GRAYSON ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
FORTY TWO NO T<c.cyan>. THANK YOU</c>
MISTER GRAYSON MISS WALDRON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR VOTE
CHANGE. THANK YOU. WALDRON A.
B. EIGHT THREE THREE I TO NOT
VOTING. ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT THIRTY
THREE I TO NOT VOTING. MR
MULLIN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR VOTE CHANGE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER VOTE CHANGE
MULLIN. AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. I TO NOT VOTING. GO
CHANGE MULLIN SOME GIRLS
FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT TO NOT
VOTING. BIGGEST MULLIN MS
BURKE. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR VOTE CHANGE AB TWO EIGHTY
THREE I'D NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE SOMETHING
GO TO EIGHTY THREE I TO NOT
VOTING. MISS PETRIE-NORRIS YOUR
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR VOTE CHANGE.
THE CHANGE PETRIE-NORRIS SP ONE
ONE THREE I IT'S NOT THIRTY.
PRO CHANGE SOMETHING REPEAT YOU
NORRIS SENATE BILL ONE THIRTEEN
I TO NOT VOTING. MR LACKEY YOUR
RECOGNIZE FAVOR CHANGE. THANK
YOU SPEAKER VOTE CHANGE FROM AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY I LIKE TO KNOW.
BEAU CHANGE LACKEY ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTY THIRTY ODD TO
KNOW. THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY
MR BONTA YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR BILL CHANGE THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
VOTE CHANGE BONTA A. B. FIFTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT I TO NOT VOTING.
PRO CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA SOME AGO FIFTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT I TO NOT VOTING. MR KILEY
HERE RECOGNIZE REVO CHANGE AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY I KNOW. BEAU
CHANGE ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILEY
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY THIRTY
I'D TO KNOW THANK YOU MISTER
KILEY IS BOERNER HORVATH YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR VOTE
CHANGE YES AB SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN.
I TO NOT VOTING. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURKE BOERNER HORVATH ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN I TO NOT
VOTING. THANK YOU
. MEMBERS I'M
FIRST PREPARE TO LIFT THE CALL
ON ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. LOCAL POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. MEMBERS THIS IS ON
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN REQUIRES FORTY ONE VOTES
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. MEMBERS JUST
TAKES FORTY ONE VOTES
. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS TAKES
FORTY ONE VOTES MEMBERS. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY ONE
KNOWS TWENTY FOUR. THE SENATE
MINUTES ARE CONCURRENT
. MEMBERS
WERE MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
. I
NUMBERS MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
TO SET SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY SEPTEMBER
THIRTEENTH FLOOR SESSION WILL
START AT NOON. TELL FIGHTING
GUYS JUST ACCEPTED. IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED MEMBERS WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS I'D ASK YOU TO
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE. COLLEAGUES
SEEKING TO MAKE IT ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY WOULD YOU PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN AT MEMORY.
WILL MOVE TO THOSE ADJOURNMENTS
AS SOON AS YOU TAKE YOUR SEATS
ARE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
. LAST TIME MEMBERS
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR OR TAKE A SEAT WE'RE
MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY MEMBERS GIVE
YOUR THOUGHTFUL ATTENTION TO
YOUR COLLEAGUE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. I RISE
TO DURING THE MEMORY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS JACK THIN TANG WHO
PASSED PEACEFULLY LAST NIGHT AT
THE AGE OF NINETY TWO WITH HIS
FAMILY BY HIS SIDE. FROM CHINA
THE SACRAMENTAL IN NINETEEN
FIFTY ONE AND WORK IN THE
GROCERY BUSINESS INTO A RETIRED
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THE
PROUD MEMBER OF THE U. S. C. W.
WHO IS ALSO A LEADER IN THE
SECOND ROW CHINESE COMMUNITY.
AS A TREASURE OF THE ON CALL
MATT BENEVOLENT ASSOCIATION. HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF
THIRTY ONE YEARS JEANNIE. FOUR
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN AND FOUR CHILDREN
ONE OF WHICH IS A MEMBER OF THE
SIMPLY FAMILIES SYLVIA TANG.
WHO SERVED AS CHIEF OF STAFF TO
SIMPLY PAUL FONG. IT IS VERY
THE BILL LONG WHO MANY OF US
KNOW. PLEASE JOIN ME JOINING
THE MEMORY OF JACK HEY. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER COOPER. MISS
PETRIE-NORRIS YOUR RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
MATTHEW OLSON WHO DIED SATURDAY
AUGUST TWENTY FOURTH IN A HIT
AND RUN COLLISION JUST THREE
WEEKS BEFORE HIS NINETEENTH
BIRTHDAY. MATTHEW GRADUATED
CORONA DEL MAR HIGH SCHOOL THIS
YEAR PART OF THE CLASS OF
TWENTY NINETEEN HE WAS JUST TWO
DAYS BEFORE THE START OF HIS
FRESHMAN YEAR AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHERE HE
WAS PLANNING TO MAJOR IN
BUSINESS. HE WAS A WONDERFUL
STUDENT. A GREAT ATHLETE A
LOYAL FRIENDS. MATTHEW PLAYED
ON CREDIT ON MARS HIGH SCHOOL
BOYS BASKETBALL AND VOLLEYBALL
TEAMS. HELPING IS VOLLEYBALL
TEAM WIN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP. IN
ACADEMICS AND IN SPORTS MATTHEW
HAD A STELLAR WORK ETHIC.
WINNING AN AWARD FOR THE
VOLLEYBALL TEAMS HARDEST
WORKING PLAYER. MATTHEW WAS
ALSO PART OF ITS CAMPUSES BEST
BUDDIES CLUB FORMING DEEP
FRIENDSHIPS WITH HIS PEERS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL. UNTIL AN
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
MATTHEW WAS WELL LIKED AND MUCH
LEFT OUR COMMUNITY HAS LOST A
WONDERFUL YOUNG MAN WITH A VERY
BIG HEART. WHEN I HEARD OF
MATTHEW'S DEATH MY HEART BROKE.
FOR THE LIFE HE SHOULD HAVE HAD
FOR THE MAN YOU SHOULD HAVE
BEEN AND FOR THE FAMILY AND
FRIENDS HE'S LEFT BEHIND IN
WHOSE HEARTS ARE STILL BREAKING.
JOIN ME TODAY IN A TURNING IN
HIS MEMORY. BACON IS
PETRIE-NORRIS. MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DESK TO
BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. ALL
REQUESTS TO JR NUMBER WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. MEMBERS ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASS
AND RETAIN AND ALL MOTIONS
SHALL BE CONTINUED. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ATTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MAYES RUBIO MOVES AND
MISS CARILLO SECONDS THERE.
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL FRIDAY SEPTEMBER
THIRTEENTH AT NOON
. WALDRON
FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN AB TWO
EIGHT THREE I TO NOT VOTING.
BOTH CHANGE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WALDRON ASSEMBLY GO TO EIGHTY
THREE I TO NOT VOTING. IRWIN AB
THIRTY EIGHT I TO KNOW. THE
CHANGES WILL REMEMBER IRWIN
SOME LEGAL THIRTY EIGHT TO KNOW
IRWIN AB FORTY FIVE I TO KNOW.
WHEN ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY FIVE I
TO KNOW. IRWIN AB AT SIXTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN I TO KNOW. IRWIN
SO WE WILL SIXTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN TO KNOW
. THANK YOU.
VOEPEL ALFA BRAVO. FIVE ZERO
SIX NOTE TO HI. BILL CHANGE
SLIMMER VOEPEL SOME WIGGLE FIVE
OH SIX NO TO I'D